Hello, everyone, and welcome to your second drink of local ad. This is a great episode. We have audio clips from director Jason Reitman. Yeah. And Angela, I don't know if you remember, but when we did our original breakdown of this episode, you titled this podcast episode, Hidden Gems and Crossover Connections. I am such a dork. I do remember.
大家好，欢迎收听你们的第二杯“本地广告”。这一集非常棒。我们有导演杰森·雷特曼的音频片段。是的。安吉拉，我不知道你还记不记得，但当我们最初拆解这一集时，你给这期播客起名为“隐藏的瑰宝与交叉联系”。我真是个书呆子。我确实记得。
Guess what? So when we dove into our mailbag for the second drink, I believe we found even more hidden gyms. We did not find any more crossover connections. No, we did not. But that's okay. I think this episode still holds that title. Okay.
你猜怎么着？当我们为“第二杯”翻看我们的邮件袋时，我相信我们发现了更多隐藏的瑰宝。我们没有发现更多的交叉联系。不，我们没有。但没关系。我认为这一集仍然配得上那个标题。好的。
Let's start with an email that I found Charming from Jade A in New Zealand. You might remember, Angela, that I gave some Kit Kat facts in my Fast Facts. Sure. Well, Jade wrote in and said, quote, I would like to just say that I found your Kit Kat facts to be an amusing revelation. I have never heard the Kit Kat jingle that Andy was singing in the episode. No idea why, but maybe we have different advertising in New Zealand. Our Kit Kat jingle is, have a break, have a Kit Kat.
让我们从我发现的一封来自新西兰Jade A的迷人邮件开始。安吉拉，你可能还记得，我在“快速事实”中提供了一些奇巧巧克力（Kit Kat）的事实。当然。嗯，Jade写信说，引用一下，“我只想说，我发现你们关于奇巧巧克力的事实是一个有趣的启示。我从来没听过安迪在剧中唱的那首奇巧巧克力广告歌。不知道为什么，也许我们在新西兰的广告不同。我们的奇巧巧克力广告歌是：休息一下，来块奇巧巧克力。”
I mean, I don't know if I'm singing it right, but instead of give me a break, break me off a piece of that Kit Kat bar. Yeah, you were singing it to the same tune. But they might have their own tune. They might have their own tune. But their jingle is have a break, have a Kit Kat. So Jade said, I always thought that break me off a piece of that fancy feast was the correct ending to the jingle that was stuck in Andy's head. They clearly also don't have fancy feast cat food there.
我的意思是，我不知道我唱得对不对，但不是“给我休息一下，掰一块奇巧巧克力棒给我”。是的，你唱的是同一个调子。但他们可能有自己的曲调。他们可能有自己的曲调。但他们的广告歌是“休息一下，来块奇巧巧克力”。所以Jade说，“我一直以为‘掰一块盛宴（Fancy Feast）给我’是安迪脑子里那首歌的正确结尾。”他们显然在新西兰也没有盛宴猫粮。
I guess not. Jade said I found this very amusing. And after watching the office so many times, I'm glad to have found a new joke to laugh at. I love that. I love it that our podcast revealed that to her. That reminds me of when Billy Elish was on. Yes. Then she had, what was it?
我想没有。Jade说，“我觉得这非常有趣。在看了这么多遍《办公室》之后，我很高兴能发现一个新的笑话来笑一笑。”我喜欢这个。我很高兴我们的播客向她揭示了这一点。这让我想起了比莉·艾利什（Billie Eilish）来的时候。是的。然后她有，是什么来着？
She thought Bono was from Scranton. From Scranton. Oh my gosh. This is also the episode where Michael has his big idea to start a restaurant where you only eat cereal. Yes, Mike's cereal shack. That's right. And you wondered, Jenna, if anyone had ever opened a cereal shack. Well, we got a fan mail flurry.
她以为波诺（Bono）来自斯克兰顿。来自斯克兰顿。天哪。这一集也是迈克尔想出他的伟大点子，开一家只吃麦片的餐厅的时候。是的，迈克尔的麦片小屋。没错。珍娜，你当时想知道是否有人开过麦片小屋。嗯，我们收到了大量的粉丝来信。
We got so many letters from people. sharing about cereal shacks. Wow. I mean, it's too many to read, but I want to share a few. McKinsey T. He wrote in and said, I have some info for your deep dive about Mike's cereal shack. There is a place near my home in Utah called Sturs that has put Michael Scott's business model into action. They have over 75 name brand cereals, and their slogan is, quote, changing the way you eat cereal. Wow. Right? And then McKinsey goes on to say, P.S., I love your podcast so much and look forward to it every week. you brighten my Wednesdays. Oh, thank you. Here's another one. Brittany Y says, ladies, all caps. Multiple exclamation points. Hi, huge fan. There is, in fact, a cereal shop in Madrid, Spain.
我们收到了很多人的来信，分享关于麦片小屋的事。哇。我的意思是，太多了读不完，但我还是想分享几封。麦肯齐·T（McKinsey T.）写道：“我有一些关于迈克尔麦片小屋的深度信息。我家附近的犹他州有一个叫Sturs的地方，把迈克尔·斯科特的商业模式付诸实践了。他们有超过75种名牌麦片，他们的口号是：‘改变你吃麦片的方式’。”哇，对吧？然后麦肯齐继续说，“P.S. 我非常喜欢你们的播客，每周都很期待。你们点亮了我的周三。”哦，谢谢。这是另一封。布列塔尼·Y（Brittany Y.）说：“女士们，全大写。多个感叹号。嗨，超级粉丝。事实上，在西班牙马德里确实有一家麦片店。”
I took a trip there in 2019 and I had to visit it because it reminded me of Michael. Wow. How about that? In Spain. In Spain. Last one, Lacey W says, hi, ladies, not a question, but I wanted to let you know that there definitely was a cereal restaurant very similar to Mike's cereal shop. I remember because it was in Chicago. And while I was visiting on a business trip years ago, I made sure to visit it. It was called, are you ready for this? What? It was called seriality. Wow. Get it? Mm-hmm. You could get regular old cereal, but it also had all kinds of toppings. You could pick a different type of milk. The whole thing. She said it was a real hoot. Oh, wow. So there, yes, the answer to my question is, Yes. There's lots of cereal shacks. Wow. Who knew? Well, finally, I want to share two fan catches. The first one is from
我在2019年去那里旅行过，我必须去参观一下，因为它让我想起了迈克尔。哇。那怎么样？在西班牙。在西班牙。最后一封，莱西·W（Lacey W.）说：“嗨，女士们，不是问题，但我只是想让你们知道，确实有一家麦片餐厅和迈克尔的麦片小屋非常相似。我记得是因为它在芝加哥。几年前我去那里出差时，我特意去参观了。它叫，准备好了吗？什么？它叫Seriality。”哇。懂了吗？嗯。你可以买到普通的旧麦片，但它也有各种各样的配料。你可以选择不同类型的牛奶。应有尽有。她说这真是太有趣了。哦，哇。所以，是的，我问题的答案是，是的。有很多麦片小屋。哇。谁知道呢？好吧，最后，我想分享两个粉丝发现。第一个来自
Ilona N, who says, not a question, but a late catch at around 16 minutes and 45 seconds when Michael emails the ad to corporate. His email reads, quote, here is the final, final, final video. I love this, as it could imply that he either submitted multiple videos and then retracted them because they weren't perfect enough or that corporate kept requesting the submission and he delayed for the same reason. I know the podcast already aired, but it made me laugh harder than it should have. Love you too and the podcast. Oh my God. That is so funny.
伊洛娜·N（Ilona N.），她说：“不是问题，但这是一个迟来的发现。在大约16分45秒时，迈克尔把广告邮件发给公司。他的邮件写着：‘这是最终，最终，最终的视频。’我喜欢这个，因为它可能暗示他要么提交了多个视频然后撤回了，因为它们不够完美，要么是公司一直要求提交，而他因为同样的原因拖延了。我知道播客已经播出了，但这让我笑得比预想的更厉害。也爱你们和播客。”哦，天哪。那太搞笑了。
I actually think it's because he kept sending different versions. Yes, I agree. And this reminds me of like whenever we would turn in our book or if I've ever turned in a script or something I've written, I'll send it. And then the next day I'll be like, wait, no, read this one. I'm sending a new version. I like joshed it again this morning. You and I did that constantly when we wrote our book. We did. I would send it to you and I would write, okay, I'm titling this AK final. Right. Yes, that's right. And then it would be like final, final. Yeah. Well, that email handle, that also would have been a little treat from our crew members who set up that
我其实认为是因为他一直在发送不同的版本。是的，我同意。这让我想起每当我们交书稿，或者我交剧本或写的东西时，我会发出去。然后第二天我会说，等等，不，读这一版。我发了一个新版本。我今天早上又改了一次。你和我写书的时候经常那样做。我们确实做了。我会发给你，然后写道，好吧，我把这个命名为AK最终版。对。是的，没错。然后它会变成最终，最终版。是的。嗯，那个邮件标题，那也是我们剧组人员设置的一个小彩蛋
shop. You know, something like that wasn't in the script, but our crew, they might have gone to a writer and said, listen, we're going to shoot this screen. What do you want the subject line to be? Yeah. I love that. I love that attention to detail. It's a funny little joke. You have to look for it. All right. Well, finally, here's my second fan catch. You know how we see the commercials from the other branches? And at the end of their commercials, it's just all the employees like waving. Michael thinks it's so boring. Well, we got this from Joe. Joan S. Jones said, I was watching the show and I paused it twice on the Nashua commercial. I wanted to see if Holly was in the end, waving.
你知道，像那样的事情不在剧本里，但我们的剧组，他们可能去找编剧说，听着，我们要拍这个屏幕。你想要主题行是什么？是的。我喜欢那种对细节的关注。这是一个有趣的小笑话。你必须去寻找它。好吧，最后，这是我的第二个粉丝发现。你知道我们是怎么看到其他分公司的广告的吗？在他们广告的结尾，只是所有的员工在挥手。迈克尔觉得这太无聊了。嗯，我们收到了琼·S（Joan S.）的来信。琼说：“我在看节目，我在纳舒厄（Nashua）的广告上暂停了两次。我想看看霍莉（Holly）是否在结尾挥手。”
I didn't see her, and I didn't hear you ladies mention if she was in it. But since we see her at the end of the season, I would think she's already working for Dundra Mifflin around the time this commercial was made. Was this an oopsie or was that storyline not on the table yet? Oh, they didn't have her yet. No, that's why. But what a good cash. I mean, because, yeah, she would have been there. Yes, she would have been an employee at Nashua at this time. But no, maybe we'll just say she was out sick the day. They filmed the wave. Yeah. Well, that's all we've got for today. Please enjoy our second drink of local ad. Have a great rest of your year. And we will see you in 2026. See you then. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey.
我没看到她，也没听到你们女士提到她是否在里面。但既然我们在季末看到了她，我想她在这个广告制作时应该已经在邓德·米夫林（Dunder Mifflin）工作了。这是一个失误，还是那个故事情节还没提上日程？哦，他们还没让她出现。不，这就是原因。但真是个好发现。我的意思是，因为，是的，她当时应该在那里。是的，她当时应该是纳舒厄的员工。但没关系，也许我们只能说她拍挥手那天请病假了。是的。好吧，这就是我们今天所有的内容。请享受我们的第二杯“本地广告”。祝你们余下的时间过得愉快。我们2026年见。到时候见。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。
on the office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Welcome to office ladies, everyone. Hello. Hi. Good morning or good afternoon or maybe good evening. We don't know when you listen. No. So we're going to cover all of it. What if I was like, actually we do? What? We are here today to talk about local ad, season four, episode nine, which I'm going to declare a hidden gem.
一起在《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会拆解一集《办公室》，并提供只有两个在场的人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士。欢迎大家收听《办公室》女士。你好。嗨。早上好，或者下午好，或者也许是晚上好。我们不知道你什么时候听。不。所以我们要涵盖所有内容。如果我说，其实我们知道呢？什么？我们今天在这里讨论“本地广告”，第四季第九集，我要宣布它是一个隐藏的瑰宝。
Whenever you say I'm going to declare, you know where my brain goes. I can't help it. Bankruptcy? Yes. For the rest of my life, I'm just going to walk this earth. And someone's going to be like, I declare it. And I'm going to think, bankrupt. Yeah.
每当你说明“我要宣布”时，你知道我的大脑会去哪里。我忍不住。破产？是的。在我的余生里，我只是会走在这个地球上。有人会说，我宣布。然后我会想，破产。是的。
You can't help it. It's like that's what she said. We can't help it. That's what she said. I don't know. It doesn't work. It is a gym. Let's hear about it, Jenna.
你忍不住。就像那是她说的。我们忍不住。那是她说的。我不知道。它不管用。它是一个瑰宝。让我们听听关于它的内容，珍娜。
It was written by B.J. Novak and directed by Jason Reitman. Here is a summary. When the Scranton branch is asked to participate in a Dunder-Mifflin television ad, Michael seizes his chance to exhibit his creativity and enlists the help and talents of his employees. I mean, has Michael ever had a more exciting day at work? No. I can't imagine the giddiness that he had how he woke up to his bacon on his George Foreman grill by his bed. He ate it real fast. Nudged Jan because shoes passed out and went to work.
它由B.J.诺瓦克（B.J. Novak）编剧，杰森·雷特曼（Jason Reitman）导演。这是一个摘要。当斯克兰顿分公司被要求参与邓德·米夫林的电视广告时，迈克尔抓住了展示他创造力的机会，并争取了员工的帮助和才华。我的意思是，迈克尔在工作中度过过比这更令人兴奋的一天吗？没有。我无法想象他有多么兴奋，他是如何被床边乔治·福尔曼烤架上的培根香醒的。他吃得很快。推了推简，因为她睡着了，然后去上班。
He is on fire today. Also in this episode, Dwight explores the online world of second life as a means of escaping his real life pain about his breakup with Angela. And Andy will not stop asking Dwight's advice in his pursuit of Angela. It's just torturing poor Dwight. It is. Have you ever had a crush where your friend was maybe liking the same guy but was doing better or something? And they'd be like, hey, he said this. What should I say back? And you're just like, oh, it's the worst. It is. Poor, poor Dwight. Well, let's get into some fast facts. Fast fact number one. Like I said, this episode is directed by Jason Reitman. Jason Reitman, Golden Globe nominated for his movie, Thank You for Smoking.
他今天状态极佳。在这一集中，德怀特（Dwight）探索了“第二人生”的在线世界，以此作为逃避他与安吉拉分手带来的现实生活痛苦的手段。而安迪（Andy）会不停地向德怀特寻求关于追求安吉拉的建议。这简直是在折磨可怜的德怀特。确实是。你有没有过这样的暗恋，你的朋友可能喜欢同一个家伙，但表现得更好或者什么的？他们会说，嘿，他说了这个。我该怎么回？而你只是觉得，哦，这是最糟糕的。确实。可怜的，可怜的德怀特。好吧，让我们进入一些快速事实。快速事实一。就像我说的，这一集由杰森·雷特曼导演。杰森·雷特曼，凭借电影《感谢你抽烟》获得金球奖提名。
He also won the Independent Spirit Award for Best Screenplay for that, and Academy Award nominated Director of Juno, among many other things. I mean, amazing. Yeah. Now, when he came to direct The Office, he had finished Juno, but it had not come out yet. So all of those accolades were in his future. But one of the stars of Juno was Rain Wilson. Yes. A little connection.
他还因此获得了独立精神奖最佳剧本奖，并且是《朱诺》的奥斯卡提名导演，还有许多其他成就。我的意思是，太棒了。是的。现在，当他来执导《办公室》时，他已经完成了《朱诺》，但它还没有上映。所以所有这些荣誉都在他的未来。但《朱诺》的主演之一是雷恩·威尔森（Rainn Wilson）。是的。一个小联系。
Mm-hmm. And Jenna, I'm not going to let you do your fast facts, but this whole episode for me is about crossover connections with people. Oh, local ad, colon, crossover connections. Local ad, colon, hidden gym slash crossover connections. There it is. Hashtag. I'm kidding. That's what she said. That's what she said. Jenna, I have been emailing with Jason over these last few months because Oscar
嗯。珍娜，我不会让你做你的快速事实，但这一整集对我来说都是关于人与人之间的交叉联系。哦，“本地广告”，冒号，交叉联系。本地广告，冒号，隐藏的瑰宝/交叉联系。就是这样。标签。我在开玩笑。那是她说的。那是她说的。珍娜，过去几个月我一直在和杰森发邮件，因为奥斯卡
and Brian and I were part of Jason's remake of the Princess Bride for Quibi. It was so good. It was so fun. And we all shot it, you know, separately, like at our homes. And then Jason edited together all the dialogue. I played Vizzini, Oscar played Enigo, and Brian played Fessick. It was so much fun. So we were trading emails.
和布莱恩（Brian）还有我参与了杰森为Quibi翻拍的《公主新娘》。太棒了。太有趣了。我们都在家里分别拍摄了它。然后杰森剪辑了所有的对话。我扮演维齐尼（Vizzini），奥斯卡扮演伊尼戈（Inigo），布莱恩扮演费西克（Fezzik）。太有趣了。所以我们一直在交换邮件。
And I was like, hey, by the way, local ad is coming up. We'd you send in some audio clips. And he was so generous. These are so great. I'm excited for you guys to hear him. Of course, the first thing we asked him was how he came to direct on the office, and here is what he had to say. Like any human being who was alive at the time, I was an enormous fan of the office. I thought it was the greatest thing on television.
我说，嘿，顺便说一下，“本地广告”快到了。你愿意发一些音频片段吗？他非常慷慨。这些太棒了。我很兴奋你们能听到。当然，我们问他的第一件事是他如何来执导《办公室》的，这是他要说的。就像当时活着的所有人一样，我是《办公室》的超级粉丝。我认为这是电视上最伟大的东西。
It was this collection of the greatest talent, actors and writers, who were making a generation-defining comedy, which was somehow sweet but always subversive, and the storytelling was great. you know, feature directors that I really admired had already come and directed the show like Harold Ramos. I think I had already directed Raine in Juneau, and I had these little connections to other people on the show. I feel like I knew a fair amount of the cast and some writers on the show already. I don't even know why, but either my agent reached out and said, hey, do you want to direct any television? And I think my response was I would be up for directing the office. And Rain made it even sound like a better opportunity by saying, look, the worst you can do when you direct the office is get a B plus
它是最伟大的天才、演员和作家的集合，他们正在制作一部定义一代人的喜剧，它既甜蜜又总是具有颠覆性，而且故事讲述得很好。你知道，我非常钦佩的剧情片导演已经来执导过这部剧了，比如哈罗德·雷米斯（Harold Ramis）。我想我已经执导过雷恩的《朱诺》了，我和剧中的其他人也有这些小联系。我觉得我已经相当了解剧中的大部分演员和一些编剧了。我甚至不知道为什么，但要么是我的经纪人联系我说，嘿，你想执导电视节目吗？我想我的回答是我愿意执导《办公室》。雷恩甚至通过说“看，执导《办公室》最差的结果是得B+”让它听起来像一个更好的机会
and the best you can do is an A. Oh, well, all right. I mean, I always used to tell people that directing the office was like someone asking you, do you want to drive my Lamborghini? And it's like, okay, it's just a, it was a show. And clearly, particularly when I came in, because I came in in season four, that so clearly knew exactly who it was. was and how it was made that as a director, really, you are simply the first audience and you have
最好的结果是A。哦，好吧，好吧。我的意思是，我过去常告诉人们，执导《办公室》就像有人问你，你想开我的兰博基尼吗？这就像，好吧，它只是一个，它是一部剧。显然，特别是当我进来的时候，因为我是第四季进来的，它非常清楚自己是谁，它是如何制作的，所以作为导演，你实际上只是第一个观众，你有
the opportunity to maybe, you know, point a couple of people in the right direction. But otherwise, as a director on the office, it's a learning experience and a joyful one. How about a hidden gem of an audio clip, Jason? And crossover connections. Yes. It's all there. I love what he said about directing the office was like if your friend said, hey, do you want to drive my Lamborghini? Like, so nice. We also asked Jason if he had any first impressions of, you know, being on the set and being with all of us.
机会也许，你知道，指引几个人走上正确的方向。但除此之外，作为《办公室》的导演，这是一次学习经历，也是一次快乐的经历。来一个隐藏的瑰宝音频片段怎么样，杰森？还有交叉联系。是的。都在那里。我喜欢他说的关于执导《办公室》就像如果你的朋友说，嘿，你想开我的兰博基尼吗？太好了。我们还问杰森，他对在片场和我们所有人在一起有什么第一印象。
I remember getting there and I was just blown away by the directing process that the camera operators were meant to be performers themselves. And unlike anything I'd ever directed in the past, I was given a floor plan and asked to draw out the performance of the camera operators, which direction they would go and which direction they would look, because the idea was that within a single take, you should be able to cover every camera angle that can be used in the editing of a scene. So this was a unique challenge as a director and kind of a thrilling one where you knew that there was eight shots you wanted to get off a wide, a couple mediums, close-ups, and you wanted to be able to pan into reactions,
我记得到了那里，我被摄像过程所震撼，摄像师本身就是表演者。与我过去执导的任何东西不同，我得到了一份平面图，并被要求画出摄像师的表演，他们会走哪个方向，看哪个方向，因为想法是在一个镜头内，你应该能够覆盖在场景剪辑中可以使用的每一个摄像机角度。所以这对导演来说是一个独特的挑战，也是一种令人兴奋的挑战，你知道你想拍八个镜头，一个广角，几个中景，特写，你想能够平移到反应，
and that somehow you had two cameras, you had two operators, and they were going to going to need to catch all these things without catching each other and they would duck under desks as one would hand by the other. It was like doing Sudoku. It was like this fun problem to solve and at the same time a thrill to watch the actual operators who knew how to do it. I remember the set was freezing cold, which was Steve Carell's request, if I remember right, you know, this whole cold, this comedy thing. I love that. I love cold. So that was fine by me. Okay. Here's what I have to say about that audio clip. What? The two things. that he mentions are one, just incredible, masterful choreography of the camera work and that it was
而且不知何故你有两台摄像机，你有两名操作员，他们需要捕捉所有这些东西而不互相干扰，他们会躲在桌子下面，因为一个人会从另一个人身边经过。这就像做数独。这就像一个有趣的难题要解决，同时观看真正知道怎么做的人操作也是一种快感。我记得片场冷得要命，如果我没记错的话，这是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔（Steve Carell）的要求，你知道，这种冷，这种喜剧的东西。我喜欢那个。我喜欢冷。所以这对我来说没问题。好吧。这就是我要说的关于那个音频片段的内容。什么？他提到的两件事是，第一，令人难以置信的、精湛的摄像编排，而且它是
freezing cold. That should tell you how cold our set was. I mean, I have pictures of people that weren't in scenes like hair and makeup and full-on parkas with hoods up and gloves. But I am really glad that Jason described the sort of dance that our cameraman did. I mean, we've talked about it a little bit, but I thought he was very eloquent in how he described it. it was a really just fascinating, beautiful thing to watch. If you weren't in the scene and you could watch those guys and I was like always so impressed. And I imagine especially weird to see the first time walking onto our set and seeing all that they did to get the shot. Yeah. One of the things I remember about Jason is him breaking and laughing when we did talking heads. I just remember him cracking up
冷得要命。这应该能让你知道我们的片场有多冷。我是说，我有那些没在拍戏的人的照片，比如发型师和化妆师，他们都穿着全套的派克大衣，戴着兜帽和手套。但我真的很高兴杰森描述了我们摄影师跳的那种舞。我是说，我们之前稍微聊过这个，但我认为他描述得非常生动。看着那样的场景真的很迷人，很美。如果你当时不在现场，能看着那些家伙工作，我总是印象深刻。我想第一次走进我们的片场，看到他们为了拍好镜头所做的一切，感觉一定特别奇怪。是的。关于杰森，我记得的一件事是，我们在拍访谈片段时，他会笑场。我只记得他笑得停不下来。
Because I had one in this. And there were also some in the deleted scenes that didn't make it in. So he must have had a whole day of talking heads. And he talked about it in the DVD commentary that one of the things he wasn't really prepared for as a director on this show is how the director is part of the cast. Because the director sits in the conference room when you do talking heads. And we talk directly to the director. Yes. As part of the mockumentary.
因为我在这一集里有一个访谈。而且还有一些被删减的片段没能放进去。所以他一定拍了一整天的访谈。他在DVD评论音轨里谈到过，作为这部剧的导演，他没真正准备好的一件事就是导演也是演员阵容的一部分。因为当你拍访谈时，导演就坐在会议室里。我们是直接对着导演说话的。是的。作为伪纪录片的一部分。
And he said he kept laughing. and that is my memory too. Yes. You're so right. We'll talk about it when we get to it, but Pam has a talking head that we could not get through. Well, we're really grateful
他说他一直在笑。这也是我的记忆。是的。你说得太对了。等我们聊到那儿的时候再细说，但帕姆有一个访谈片段，我们怎么也拍不下去。好吧，我们真的很感激
that Jason sent in these clips and we have even more. We'll sprinkle them throughout the episode. Yes. Next up is Fast fact number two, which is all about Second Life. Oh, Jenna, let me tell you, when I rewatch this
杰森寄来了这些片段，我们还有更多。我们会在这一集中穿插播放。是的。接下来是第二个速记事实，全是关于《第二人生》的。哦，珍娜，让我告诉你，当我重看这一集时
and saw the Second Life storyline, I was like, oh, I know my lady, Jenna Fisher is going to do a deep dive on this because you love these kind of games. You play these kind of games. Well, I played The Sims. Yes. Which is very different from Second Life. Oh. By the way, Second Life is real and it still exists today. And like Dwight says in the episode, it's not a game. Sims is a game where you have a character and you have to eat food and go to the bathroom and have a job and try to build a mansion and things like that. This is what I remember, Jenna. I remember you built a whole world. You are working on your world. Isn't that like a second. A little bit. You know, I stopped playing Sims when I had built myself a little house and I had a little cat that was just like my real cat, Andy. And in the game, I was petting my
看到《第二人生》的剧情线，我就想，哦，我知道我的好姐妹珍娜·费舍尔肯定会深入研究这个，因为你喜欢这类游戏。你玩过这种游戏。嗯，我玩过《模拟人生》。是的。这和《第二人生》非常不同。哦。顺便说一下，《第二人生》是真实的，而且今天依然存在。就像德怀特在剧中所说，它不是游戏。《模拟人生》是一个游戏，你有一个角色，你必须吃东西、上厕所、找工作，还要尝试建造豪宅之类的。这就是我记得的，珍娜。我记得你建立了一个完整的世界。你在经营你的世界。那不就像是第二个（人生）吗？有一点。你知道，当我给自己盖了一栋小房子，还有一只像我现实中的猫安迪一样的猫时，我就不再玩《模拟人生》了。在游戏里，我正在抚摸我的
fake cat and I looked over at my real cat who was like, and I thought, yeah, I need to get out of this game and pet my real cat. Oh, man. So Second Life, it predated Twitter and Instagram and social media, and it was almost like a virtual online chat room. You created an avatar of yourself, and then you could go in and interact with other people's avatars. Like Reddit, like if I animated myself and then I could go in a Reddit chat room? Yes, very similar. But you can build things. You could build a little hotel and run it, and then other avatars could come to your hotel. Oh, that's kind of fun. You can go to a concert. There were, college classes, press conferences that you could attend as your avatar, and you could even buy
假猫，然后我看向我现实中的猫，它当时正看着我，我想，是的，我得退出这个游戏，去摸摸我真正的猫。天哪。所以《第二人生》比推特、Instagram和社交媒体出现得更早，它几乎就像一个虚拟的在线聊天室。你创建了一个自己的化身，然后你可以进去与别人的化身互动。就像Reddit，如果我把自己动画化，然后我可以进入一个Reddit聊天室？是的，非常相似。但你可以建造东西。你可以盖一家小旅馆并经营它，然后其他化身可以来到你的旅馆。哦，那挺有趣的。你可以去听音乐会。还有大学课程、新闻发布会，你可以以化身的身份参加，甚至可以购买
land, shop for clothes and gadgets, visit with friends. It was this online world. It was created by Lyndon Lab. And it was just like a social experience. It wasn't a game. You didn't win anything, but you could earn money in the game that you would then spend on these different experiences. I get it. I could see where that would be really fun. It kind of reminds me. a little bit of this movie we just watched with the kids called Ready Player One. Mm-hmm. You sort of design your avatar and then you get to go explore and interact with other people. I've not seen that movie, but that sounds on point.
土地、购买衣服和配件、拜访朋友。这是一个在线世界。它是由林登实验室创建的。它就像一种社交体验。它不是游戏。你赢不了什么，但你可以在游戏中赚取金钱，然后花在这些不同的体验上。我明白了。我能看出这为什么会很有趣。它让我想起了一点我们刚和孩子们一起看的电影，叫《头号玩家》。嗯。你设计你的化身，然后去探索并与其他人互动。我没看过那部电影，但听起来很贴切。
You should see it. Okay. I think you would like it. Okay. I'll watch the first 20 minutes of it. Yeah. Tell me about the towel next to the coffee pot. You got it.
你应该看看。好的。我想你会喜欢的。好的。我会看前20分钟。好的。跟我说说咖啡壶旁边的毛巾吧。没问题。
Is there a charming random detail I can hone in on in the first 20 minutes of the film? I'm sure you'll find it. So much shade. Okay, go on. It's good you're still not bitter about it, though. We had a fan question about Second Life from Winston F, Olivia Lovell, Gianna Williams, and John Luscombe. They just said, can you please tell us everything about using Second and Second Life on the office? It seems like such a big undertaking to program a whole massive multiplayer online game for a single episode.
在前20分钟里有什么迷人的随机细节我可以关注吗？我相信你会发现的。真是太刻薄了。好吧，继续。你还没对此怀恨在心，这很好。我们收到了关于《第二人生》的粉丝提问，来自温斯顿·F、奥利维亚·洛弗尔、吉安娜·威廉姆斯和约翰·卢斯科姆。他们只是说，你们能告诉我们关于在《办公室》里使用《第二人生》的一切吗？为了一集节目去编程一个大型多人在线游戏似乎是一项巨大的工程。
who came up with it, how did you do it? Well, you know who I had to reach out to. Kenta, Kentapedia! Kent reached out to the developers of Second Life, Clear Inc. and Linden Labs, and we entered into a license agreement with them. They ended up creating all of the avatars and animation for us. Kent had to send pictures of John and Rain over to those guys, and they drew out little avatars of them based on.
是谁想出来的，你们是怎么做到的？嗯，你知道我必须联系谁。肯塔，肯塔百科！肯联系了《第二人生》的开发商Clear Inc.和林登实验室，我们与他们签订了许可协议。他们最终为我们制作了所有的化身和动画。肯不得不把约翰和雷恩的照片发给那些人，他们根据杰森和格雷格的指示画出了他们的小化身。
on Jason and Greg's direction. And that's how they made it. It's so cool. And Kent is so awesome. We go to Kent every week. I know. Thanks, Kent. We got a letter, Angela, from Sin Skyberg. And listen to this. I worked at Second Life when this episode came out and we were so excited. I was the head of customer service at the time and I got all our team together virtually to watch the episode. Second Life was and is a crazy place and so much really nuts of stuff happened in there. This was a big highlight for all of us. I bet sin has some good stories. No. I didn't want to open up that Pandora's box because I thought, oh no, I don't want to get anyone in trouble. But how cool. I am now curious. That is so cool. Are you ready for fast fact number three? Y'all. I'm calling
这就是他们制作的方式。太酷了。而且肯太棒了。我们每周都会找肯。我知道。谢谢你，肯。安吉拉，我们收到了一封来自辛·斯凯伯格的信。听听这个。这一集播出时我在《第二人生》工作，我们太兴奋了。当时我是客户服务主管，我把我们整个团队召集在一起，虚拟地观看了这一集。《第二人生》过去和现在都是一个疯狂的地方，里面发生了太多真正疯狂的事情。这对我们所有人来说都是一个巨大的亮点。我敢打赌辛一定有一些好故事。不。我不想打开那个潘多拉魔盒，因为我想，哦不，我不想让任何人惹上麻烦。但太酷了。我现在很好奇。那太酷了。准备好迎接第三个速记事实了吗？大家。我称
this one Kit Kat Fun Facts. Oh, did you do a deep dive on KitKat? Lady, of course I did. As you know, in this episode, the character of Andy cannot remember the end of the famous jingle, Give me a break, give me a break, break me off a piece of that Kit Kat Bar. Yeah, so I thought y'all might like to know that the Kit Kat Bar was brought to market in 1930 by Roundtree of York in the United Kingdom. It was advertised as the best companion to a cup of tea. Round Tree of York, maker of chocolate, seventh of its name, best companion cup of tea. I don't know.
这个为奇巧巧克力趣味事实。哦，你对奇巧巧克力做了深入研究吗？姐妹，我当然做了。如你所知，在这一集中，安迪这个角色记不住那首著名广告歌的结尾，“给我一个休息，给我一个休息，掰给我一块奇巧巧克力棒”。是的，所以我认为你们可能想知道，奇巧巧克力棒是1930年由英国约克的朗特里公司推向市场的。它被宣传为喝茶时的最佳伴侣。约克的朗特里，巧克力制造商，第七代传人，喝茶的最佳伴侣。我不知道。
I'm sorry, I just make everything a Game of Thrones title. Even though I never finished Game of Thrones like John Wick, I love your Game of Thrones names that you make, Angela. Thank you. I feel seen somewhat. The jingle that Andy can't remember debuted in the United States in 1986, and it is still the jingle today. The words are by Ken Scholdman, and the music was written by Michael A. Levine. Versions of the original have been covered by Carrie Underwood, Sean Colvin, and countless actors who have been seen in the commercials. But here's where it gets interesting.
抱歉，我只是把一切都变成了《权力的游戏》标题。尽管我从未像看完《疾速追杀》那样看完《权力的游戏》，但我喜欢你起的那些《权力的游戏》名字，安吉拉。谢谢。我觉得自己多少被注意到了。安迪记不住的那首广告歌于1986年在美国首次亮相，至今仍在使用。歌词由肯·肖尔德曼创作，音乐由迈克尔·A·莱文创作。原版已被凯莉·安德伍德、肖恩·科尔文以及无数在广告中露面的演员翻唱过。但有趣的地方来了。
Okay. This song, the Kit Katjohn. jingle was cited in a study by a researcher at the University of Cincinnati who declared it one of the top 10 earworms. An earworm is a bit of a melody or bit of a song that becomes stuck in your head. Oh yes. The researcher's name is James Caleris and he studied this phenomenon. Why do bits of songs get stuck in our heads? He said that it happens to almost everyone at some point in their life, but he found that it did happen more to women and musicians. Hmm.
好的。这首奇巧巧克力的广告歌被辛辛那提大学的一位研究人员在研究中引用，他将其列为十大“耳虫”之一。“耳虫”是指一段旋律或歌曲片段，会在你脑海中挥之不去。哦，是的。研究人员的名字叫詹姆斯·卡莱里斯，他研究了这种现象。为什么歌曲片段会卡在我们的脑海里？他说几乎每个人在生命中的某个时刻都会遇到这种情况，但他发现这种情况在女性和音乐家身上发生得更多。嗯。
Huh. I have had by Minnan stuck in my head for years. Oh. Okay, that was not on his list, but do you know what was on his list of wormiest songs? Let's hear it. The Chili's Jingle Baby Back Ribs. Oh, yes. Which has also been featured on The Office.
哈。我的脑子里多年来一直回荡着《By Minnan》。哦。好吧，那不在他的名单上，但你知道他的“最洗脑歌曲”名单上有什么吗？说来听听。奇利斯的广告歌《Baby Back Ribs》。哦，是的。这首歌也曾在《办公室》中出现过。
The other songs that made the top 10 were, We Will Rock You, Who Let the Dogs Out? the Mission Impossible theme song, Womp, there it is, the lion sleeps tonight, it's a small world after all, NYMCA. Those are the wormiest songs. The wormiest songs.
进入前十名的其他歌曲还有，《We Will Rock You》、《Who Let the Dogs Out?》、《碟中谍》主题曲、《Womp, there it is》、《The Lion Sleeps Tonight》、《It's a Small World After All》、《YMCA》。这些是最洗脑的歌曲。最洗脑的歌曲。
Well, I guess by Menon isn't really a song. No, but it's a bit of melody. Yes. So you don't get the whole song trapped in your head. You just get some little bit of the melody stuck in your head. Yeah, there you go. Well, I feel like everybody, you could probably walk down the street, and stick a microphone in someone's face and say, give me a break, and they'd immediately go into it.
好吧，我想《By Minnan》算不上是一首歌。不，但它是一段旋律。是的。所以你脑子里并没有整首歌。你只是脑子里卡住了一点点旋律。是的，就是这样。好吧，我觉得每个人，你可能走在街上，把麦克风塞到某人脸上说，“给我一个休息”，他们会立刻唱出来。
Yeah, everyone knows that. That's all I got, lady. I thought those were wonderful fast facts. I'm excited to get into this episode. I've got some stuff coming up. Well, I hope it's a ton of hidden gems and crossover connections. I just want to remind you that's the theme of this episode. Thank you for the reminder. Let's take a break and come back with some more hidden gems and local ad. Make your home smell as good as it looks with Pura 4, the smart fragrance diffuser that lets you control your scent from anywhere. Choose from hundreds of premium fragrances, schedule your favorites, and set the perfect mood for every moment. And right now, get yours free when you subscribe to two cents for 12 months. Don't wait, this limited time offer won't last.
是的，每个人都知道。我就这些了，姐妹。我觉得这些速记事实太棒了。我很兴奋能进入这一集。我还有些内容要讲。好吧，我希望那是大量的隐藏彩蛋和跨剧联系。我只是想提醒你，这是这一集的主题。谢谢你的提醒。让我们休息一下，回来后再聊更多隐藏彩蛋和本地广告。用Pura 4让你的家闻起来和看起来一样好，这是一款智能香氛扩散器，让你可以在任何地方控制香味。从数百种优质香氛中选择，安排你最喜欢的香味，为每一刻营造完美的氛围。现在，订阅12个月的两款香氛，即可免费获得设备。别等了，这个限时优惠不会持续太久。
Try it risk-free for 30 days now at pura.com. All right. So this episode starts with a conference room scene. Michael is getting the gang to brainstorm ideas for their upcoming commercial. He's super excited. Right at the top, Phyllis shouts out, Dancing Baby. Jenna, you know what she's talking about, right? There were those commercials with dancing babies in them, right? It was this phenomenon. Okay, here's my little mini deep dive guys. It's referred to as the Ucacaca baby. It was a 3D rendered animation of a a baby dancing. It became a media phenomenon. It was one of the very first viral videos in the 90s. It was this dancing baby animation. It went all over these popular web forums, websites. It got
现在就在pura.com上免费试用30天。好的。所以这一集以会议室场景开始。迈克尔正让大家为即将到来的广告头脑风暴。他超级兴奋。刚开始，菲利斯就喊出了“跳舞的婴儿”。珍娜，你知道她在说什么，对吧？那些有跳舞婴儿的广告，对吧？这是一种现象。好的，这是我的小深度研究，伙计们。它被称为“Ucacaca婴儿”。这是一个3D渲染的跳舞婴儿动画。它成为了媒体现象。它是90年代最早的病毒视频之一。就是这个跳舞婴儿动画。它传遍了所有流行的网络论坛和网站。它被
emailed to people, demo videos, commercials. Eventually, it ended up in mainstream television. It was featured on CBS, CNN. And then what I remember it from is it ended up being part of these like fantasy kind of things that Ali McBeal would have on her show. Oh yes. Oh, yes. Right? Yes, the dancing baby on Ellie McBeal. I remember that. So this was one of the very first viral videos. And I went back and watched it. It's so creepy. It's so creepy. I have to put it in our stories. It is just the creepiest thing. America, what did we love about it? Sometimes you look back and you're like, why did we go so crazy over that thing? I think because we'd never seen anything like it. This was like sort of the beginning of what memes and gifts or gifs, what are you called those? This was, was the beginning of that. This was this 3D animated baby dancing awkwardly to this song. And people were like, oh, my guy. Lady, also at the very beginning of this episode, we had a fan catch from Linda Kay, Sadie K. And Jackie Hewitt, in the background of Michael's talking head, Angela, you are way out of character. What is going on there? It's at 16 seconds, everybody, 16 seconds. I know. I have.
通过电子邮件发给人们、演示视频、广告。最终，它进入了主流电视。它在哥伦比亚广播公司、美国有线电视新闻网播出。我记得它是因为它最终成为了《甜心俏佳人》剧中那些幻想场景的一部分。哦，是的。哦，是的。对吧？是的，《甜心俏佳人》里的跳舞婴儿。我记得。所以这是最早的病毒视频之一。我回去看了看。太诡异了。太诡异了。我必须把它发到我们的故事里。这简直是最诡异的东西。美国，我们当时为什么会喜欢它？有时你回过头来看，你会想，我们为什么会对那个东西那么疯狂？我想是因为我们从未见过类似的东西。这就像是模因和GIF的开端，你们管那些叫什么？这就是开端。这是一个3D动画婴儿尴尬地跳着这首歌。人们当时想，哦，我的天。姐妹，在这一集的开头，我们还有来自琳达·凯、萨迪·K和杰基·休伊特的粉丝发现，在迈克尔的访谈背景里，安吉拉，你完全不在状态。那里发生了什么？在16秒处，大家，16秒。我知道。我有。
I took a screen grab of it. I am literally laughing. And then I just start chatting away. You see my mouth going? I am so out of character. I clearly didn't realize I was in the shot. Sometimes they would have Steve do talking heads right outside the conference room. And we were in the background, but it was like a little blurry, you know? Yeah. And I didn't realize. But I looked and it's Rain, Brian, me, you, and Ed. And I guess I'm telling a story. you are holding court you are seated with your legs crossed and we're all kind of standing around you and you are clearly telling a very fun story I know I caught it too it was amazing also it sets up in this scene though great runner of Andy not being able to remember the end of the Kit Kat jingle and Jim immediately says don't help him so no one helps him I know that is the worst I know It also sets up that Pam has volunteered to make a logo for Michael's commercial. She's going to design a logo. She's very excited.
我截了图。我简直笑死了。然后我就开始聊天了。你看到我的嘴在动吗？我完全不在状态。我显然没意识到我在镜头里。有时他们会让史蒂夫在会议室外做访谈。我们在背景里，但有点模糊，你知道吗？是的。我没意识到。但我看了看，是雷恩、布莱恩、我、你和埃德。我想我是在讲故事。你在主持大局，你坐着，双腿交叉，我们都站在你周围，你显然在讲一个非常有趣的故事。我知道，我也注意到了，太棒了。不过这一幕也为安迪记不住奇巧广告歌结尾的梗做了铺垫，吉姆立刻说不要帮他，所以没人帮他。我知道，那是最糟糕的。我知道。这也为帕姆自愿为迈克尔的广告制作标志做了铺垫。她要设计一个标志。她非常兴奋。
Well, she says she's taking an animation class. I love that. I know. I was like, go Pam. Next, the ad guys arrive. Michael runs out of the conference room and he is immediately going to start pitching them his ideas. He says he wants this commercial to be like MTV on crack.
嗯，她说她在上动画课。我喜欢这个。我知道。我当时想，加油帕姆。接下来，广告商来了。迈克尔跑出会议室，立刻开始向他们推销他的想法。他说他想让这个广告像嗑了药的MTV一样。
He goes around. He introduces them to. everyone in the office. There's even more in the deleted scenes. He literally goes up to like every single person and does like a horrible introduction of all of them. The way only Michael can. If you want to see some more awkward, cringy Michael introductions, go to the deleted scenes. These two ad guys were played by Kyle Bornheimer and Tim Kang. You probably recognize these guys. Kyle has been on a ton of stuff. He was on Brooklyn 9-9. He's done a bunch of commercials. Tim is the same way. He went on to be a regular on the mentalist and the
他四处走动。他把他们介绍给办公室里的每个人。删减片段里还有更多。他真的走到每个人面前，对他们做了糟糕的介绍。只有迈克尔能做到。如果你想看更多尴尬、令人畏缩的迈克尔式介绍，去看删减片段。这两个广告商由凯尔·伯恩海默和蒂姆·康饰演。你可能认得这些人。凯尔演过很多东西。他演过《神烦警探》。他拍过很多广告。蒂姆也一样。他后来成为了《超感神探》和《夏威夷神探》重启版的常驻演员。
reboot of Magnum P.I. Yes. Are you ready for some crossover connection? Lay them on me. Tim, who plays Tim, ready for this? His daughter and my daughter were on the same soccer team in 2019, the Falcons. I was the team parent. My ex-husband Warren was the coach. We make it work, y'all we make it work. And the Falcons made it to the finals in our AYSO division. We went on to play in the regional playoffs, you guys, and then we advanced to the area playoffs. The girls came in third and they were the runner-up team to go to state. Lady, I will never forget your messages to me during this time of Isabelle's soccer team going so far. It was the never-ending year of soccer. It was. I would text you and I would say, what are you up to? And you're like, lady, we are still in this soccer tournament. Yes. But it was so exciting. I remember how excited those girls were. And Tim is one of the other parents of another girl. I love that. Yes. So Tim and I have sat on the sidelines together and cheered our girls on. Well, I have a connection to Kyle. It's not as exciting as that. But we were both in the movie Blades of Glory.
是的。准备好迎接一些跨剧联系了吗？告诉我吧。蒂姆，饰演蒂姆的那位，准备好了吗？他的女儿和我的女儿在2019年是同一个足球队的，叫“猎鹰队”。我是球队家长。我的前夫沃伦是教练。我们让它运作起来，大家，我们让它运作起来。猎鹰队打进了我们AYSO赛区的决赛。我们继续参加地区季后赛，伙计们，然后我们晋级了区域季后赛。女孩们获得了第三名，她们是去参加州比赛的亚军球队。姐妹，我永远不会忘记你在伊莎贝尔足球队走得那么远的时候发给我的信息。那是没完没了的足球年。确实。我会给你发短信说，你在干什么？你说，姐妹，我们还在参加这个足球锦标赛。是的。但这太令人兴奋了。我记得那些女孩有多兴奋。蒂姆是另一个女孩的家长之一。我喜欢这个。是的。所以蒂姆和我曾坐在场边一起为我们的女孩加油。嗯，我和凯尔有联系。没那么令人兴奋。但我们都出演了电影《冰刀双人组》。
He played the rink PA announcer. And so I guess in a way, we also both sat in stands and cheered on a sporting event of ice skating, though fictional. Yes. Well, I have another crossover connection for you, Angela. I think I know this one. This one's really weird. And it's going to be a runner through this whole episode. Like every guest star in this episode, local ad, has also had a guest appearance on Monk.
他扮演溜冰场的广播员。所以我想在某种程度上，我们也都坐在看台上为一场体育赛事加油，尽管是虚构的滑冰比赛。是的。嗯，我还有另一个跨剧联系给你，安吉拉。我想我知道这个。这个真的很奇怪。而且它会贯穿这一整集。就像这一集里的每一位客串明星，本地广告，也都曾在《神探阿蒙》中客串过。
It's so wild. isn't it? What is going on? Kyle played uniform cop in Mr. Monk in the Kid, and Tim played Mr. Brennaman in Mr. Monk is up all night. I know. It's so wild to me. We have more crossover connections coming up, but there's your first two. Now we get into this episode, and it opens with Dwight playing second life. And Jenna, at three minutes, 39 seconds, is it just me, or does Dwight fly like mother, in Raised by Wolves. I don't know raised by wolves. I know.
太疯狂了，不是吗？发生了什么事？凯尔在《神探阿蒙与孩子》中扮演制服警察，蒂姆在《神探阿蒙彻夜未眠》中扮演布伦南先生。我知道。这对我来说太疯狂了。我们还有更多的跨剧联系，但这是前两个。现在我们进入这一集，开头是德怀特在玩《第二人生》。珍娜，在3分39秒，是我多心了吗，还是德怀特飞起来的样子像《异星灾变》里的母亲？我不知道《异星灾变》。我知道。
This sounds very similar to Game of Thrones. Okay. Raised by Wolves is nothing like Game of Thrones. It is just the weirdest show on HBO Max. Here's the overview of Raised by Wolves. Two androids are tasked with raising human children on a mysterious planet. As the human colony threatens to be torn apart by religious differences, the Androids learn that controlling the beliefs of humans is treacherous and a difficult task.
这听起来很像《权力的游戏》。好的。《异星灾变》和《权力的游戏》一点也不像。它只是HBO Max上最奇怪的剧。这是《异星灾变》的概述。两个机器人被指派在一个神秘的星球上抚养人类孩子。随着人类殖民地因宗教分歧而面临分裂的威胁，机器人了解到控制人类的信仰是一项危险而艰巨的任务。
Also, the android's mother is able to have babies. It's very bizarre, Jenna. It's so bizarre. It is not a surprise to me that I'm watching Last Tango in Halifax instead of Raised by Wolfe. Now, listen, Last Tango in Halifax is right up my alley. You know I love any kind of like BBC programming, but I also love me some weird sci-fi. Okay, I'm going to show you. This is how Dwight flies in simple life, and this is how mother flies. Mm-hmm. I see it. They both go upright with their arms out. It's very creepy.
而且，那个机器人的母亲还能生孩子。这太离奇了，珍娜。真是太离奇了。我居然在看《哈利法克斯最后的探戈》而不是《异星灾变》，这对我来说一点也不奇怪。听着，《哈利法克斯最后的探戈》正合我意。你知道我喜欢任何BBC的节目，但我也喜欢一些奇怪的科幻片。好吧，我要给你展示一下。这就是德怀特在《第二人生》里的飞行方式，这就是母亲的飞行方式。嗯哼。我看到了。他们都是手臂伸直，身体挺直。这太令人毛骨悚然了。
I know. Anyone else that watch Raised by Wolves, go to three minutes, 39 seconds. Watch how Dwight does his lift off, and it will remind you of mother. Angela will also put that on the pod. I'm going to put it in our stories. I looked up Dwight's profile on Second Life. You did? I did. It's still there. Here's my. what he has down as his interests, muscle cars, pop culture, and sci-fi buff. In parentheses, Harry Potter, the Lord of the Rings, Star Wars 24, alias Smallville, The Apprentice, Lost and Battlestar Galactica. His talents are listed as avid cornhusk doll maker, beat sculptor, and not-tying champion. He had to list a goal for his second life, and he wrote, to calculate the exchange between shrewd bucks and linden dollars. Linden dollars are the currency in
我知道。还有谁看了《异星灾变》，快去看3分39秒。看看德怀特是怎么起飞的，这会让你想起母亲。安吉拉也会把它发到播客上。我会把它放到我们的故事里。我查了德怀特在《第二人生》里的个人资料。你查了？我查了。它还在那儿。这是他的兴趣爱好：肌肉车、流行文化和科幻迷。括号里写着：哈利·波特、《指环王》、《星球大战》24、《双面女间谍》、《超人前传》、《学徒》、《迷失》和《太空堡垒卡拉狄加》。他的才艺列为：狂热的玉米皮娃娃制作师、节拍雕塑家和打结冠军。他必须列出一个他在《第二人生》里的目标，他写道：计算“精明币”（shrewd bucks）和“林登币”（linden dollars）之间的汇率。林登币是
second life. Okay. So there you have it. When he's not flying like mother, he is trying to calculate the exchange between shrewbucks and linden dollars. I love that. Up next, Michael is going to pitch his big idea to the ad guys. I want you guys to know a deleted scene would have come before this between Jim and Michael. That is so delicious and fun. Basically, Michael wants to practice pitch to Jim. He brings Jim in the office, right? He has Jim sit behind his desk so he can practice pitch. And he says, this is his pitch to Jim. We start on a blank piece of paper. We widen to reveal ancient Rome. Jim's like, can't do that. Michael's like, okay, we widen to reveal a spaceship blasting out of a woman's womb. What? Then they do this very funny
《第二人生》里的货币。好吧。所以就是这样。当他不模仿母亲飞行时，他就在计算精明币和林登币之间的汇率。我喜欢这个。接下来，迈克尔要向广告商推销他的大创意。我想让你们知道，在这之前本来有一个吉姆和迈克尔的删减片段。那真是太有趣、太精彩了。基本上，迈克尔想向吉姆练习推销。他把吉姆叫进办公室，对吧？他让吉姆坐在他的办公桌后面，这样他就可以练习推销了。他说，这是他给吉姆的推销词。我们从一张白纸开始。镜头拉远，显露出古罗马。吉姆说，不能那样做。迈克尔说，好吧，我们拉远镜头，显露出一艘宇宙飞船从一个女人的子宫里冲出来。什么？然后他们演了这段非常有趣的
role play where Jim's like, get out of my office. It's like, becomes a whole thing. But for real, the pitch Michael settles on is this one. And I thought we had to hear it. Sam, can you play it? Little girl in a field, hole in a flower. We zoom back to find that she's in the desert. And the field is an oasis. Zoom back further, the desert is a sandbox in the world's largest resort hotel. Zoom back further. The hotel is actually the playground of the world's largest prison. But we zoom back further. I can tell that your time is valuable.
角色扮演，吉姆说，滚出我的办公室。这变成了一整件事。但实际上，迈克尔最终确定的推销词是这个。我觉得我们必须听听。萨姆，你能播放一下吗？一个小女孩在田野里，花朵上有个洞。我们拉远镜头，发现她在沙漠里。田野是一片绿洲。再拉远，沙漠是世界上最大的度假酒店里的一个沙坑。再拉远，酒店实际上是世界上最大的监狱的操场。但我们再拉远。我看得出你的时间很宝贵。
Oh, well, I love what he says when the guy is like, listen, I can tell your time is valuable. And Michael's like, well, actually, I don't get paid by the hour anymore. I get paid by the year. So basically, I can waste as much time as I want. Not a problem. Yes. But I love that this is the pitch that he led with. and knowing that he had other ideas, but this is what he went with.
哦，我喜欢当那个人说“听着，我看得出你的时间很宝贵”时，迈克尔说的话。迈克尔说，嗯，其实我不再按小时拿工资了。我是按年拿工资的。所以基本上，我可以随心所欲地浪费时间。没问题。是的。但我喜欢这是他最先提出的推销词，而且知道他还有其他想法，但他最终选择了这个。
The ad guys are great. They're so real in how they react to Michael. They say, listen, we made something for the National Branch. Why don't we show that to you? And it'll give you an idea of what we can do. So he plays this commercial, and then they explain the only part of the commercial they're allowed to alter is the last five seconds. Yeah. And Michael's like, what?
广告商们很棒。他们对迈克尔的反应非常真实。他们说，听着，我们为国家分部做了一些东西。为什么不展示给你看呢？这会让你知道我们能做什么。于是他播放了这个广告，然后他们解释说，广告中唯一允许他们修改的部分是最后五秒钟。是的。迈克尔说，什么？
We just wave at the end. He goes, you know, you could clap, you know, make it your own. Yeah, this is where you can really get creative. You can be inside. You can be outside. We had a fan question. Aaron Jassa, Harry Driscoll, Molly Coats, and many others. They wanted to know who directed this commercial that plays in the middle of the episode.
我们最后只是挥挥手。他说，你知道，你可以鼓掌，你知道，把它变成你自己的东西。是的，这是你真正可以发挥创意的地方。你可以在室内。你可以在室外。我们有一个粉丝提问。亚伦·贾萨、哈里·德里斯科尔、莫莉·科茨和许多其他人。他们想知道是谁导演了这段在剧集中间播放的广告。
Was it Jason Reitman? Yes, it was Jason Reitman. I texted with BJ about this commercial, and he told me that Jason Reitman had directed real commercials before this. Before this. And he remembers that it was so cool. Because Jason laid out this big circular track on the floor and had the camera going around in circles. And BJ was like, I had never seen anything like that before. It was so cool.
是杰森·雷特曼吗？是的，是杰森·雷特曼。我为此和BJ发过短信，他告诉我杰森·雷特曼在这之前就导演过真正的广告。在这之前。他记得那太酷了。因为杰森在地板上铺了一条巨大的圆形轨道，让摄像机绕着圈拍。BJ说，我以前从没见过那样的东西。太酷了。
Well, we asked Jason about filming this fake commercial. And here's what he had to say. The episode Local Ad contained two commercials inside it. And I had been a commercial director. I was a bad commercial director, I should say, you know, the majority of the commercials that I directed were ones that if you saw, you would revoke my director's guild card. you would just say you're not allowed to direct again. And I would, you know, name clients, but that would be rude. But, you know, typical fast food and beer and just, but like, not good work.
好吧，我们问了杰森关于拍摄这个假广告的事。他是这么说的。这一集《本地广告》里包含了两个广告。我曾经是一名广告导演。我应该说，我是一个糟糕的广告导演，你知道，我导演的大部分广告，如果你看了，你都会吊销我的导演工会会员证。你会直接说你不允许再执导了。我会，你知道，说出客户的名字，但这很不礼貌。但是，你知道，典型的快餐和啤酒，只是，但就像，不是好的作品。
I was not Spike Jones. But I learned that format. There's certain things that you may not know how to do authentically, but you know how to satirize. Like, I know that I could never direct a David Fincher film, but I love him so much as a filmmaker that I could probably direct a satire of a David Fincher film. And so I don't know how to direct a great commercial. but I think I know how to direct the satire of a good commercial. And that was the kind of the great thing about doing the Dunder Mifflin ad
我不是斯派克·琼斯。但我学会了那种格式。有些事情你可能不知道如何真实地去做，但你知道如何讽刺。就像，我知道我永远无法导演一部大卫·芬奇的电影，但我作为电影制作人非常喜欢他，所以我可能可以导演一部大卫·芬奇电影的讽刺作品。所以我不知道如何导演一个伟大的广告，但我认为我知道如何导演一个好广告的讽刺作品。这就是制作邓德·米夫林广告的伟大之处
was I felt my commercial brain trying to do the best, worst version of what Dunder Mifflin would hand Michael Scott, which was this kind of cutesy commercial. It starred Jeff Witsky, who is an actor I've worked with since I was a kid. He literally was in my first short film and has been in everything I've ever made since. And he was the star of it, and that was great. I love that Jason just uses his friend Jeff and everything. I just think that's wonderful. Jenna, I want you to be in everything I do from here on out.
我觉得我的广告大脑试图做出邓德·米夫林会交给迈克尔·斯科特的那种最好、最差的版本，也就是这种可爱的广告。它由杰夫·维茨基主演，他是我从小就合作过的演员。他确实出演了我的第一部短片，并且从那以后我制作的每一部作品他都参与了。他是主角，这太棒了。我喜欢杰森在每部作品里都用他的朋友杰夫。我觉得这太棒了。珍娜，我希望你从现在开始参与我做的每一件事。
Great. I love it. Okay. Well, we have some crossover connections with Jeff. Are you ready? He was also in Mindy and Brenda, the TV short written by Mindy Kaling and Brenda Withers. Oh. Yeah.
太棒了。我喜欢。好吧。我们和杰夫有一些交叉联系。你准备好了吗？他也出演了《明迪和布伦达》，那是明迪·卡灵和布伦达·威瑟斯写的电视短片。哦。是的。
He played the sales clerk. Well, lady, guess what? He also did a guest spot on Monk. He played Human Cannonball and Mr. Monk Goes to the Circus. That one really got me. I might need to look that one up. Human Cannonball. Very curious. You might need to see what the human cannonball looks like. Yes. So not only did Jason hire Jeff again, he also hired a friend that he had worked with before to compose that music. That's sort of like, I don't know, it's like salsa musac that's playing in the background. It was composed by the same
他扮演了销售员。好吧，女士，你猜怎么着？他还在《神探阿蒙》里客串过。他在《阿蒙先生去马戏团》里扮演了人体炮弹。那一个真的吸引了我。我可能需要去查查那个。人体炮弹。很好奇。你可能需要看看人体炮弹长什么样。是的。所以杰森不仅再次雇用了杰夫，他还雇用了他以前合作过的朋友来创作那段音乐。那就像，我不知道，就像背景里播放的萨尔萨音乐。它是由同一位
composer that did all the music for Juno, Mateo Messina. I love that. Now things are going to get awkward. Andy pulls Dwight aside to get advice on how to get to first base with Angela. He says they've been necking a lot, but that means that they are literally rubbing their necks together. There's no kissing involved. Why don't we have any footage of that? I don't know. I don't know. Angela, we had a fan question from Amy Noki. She's dying to know what is your backstory for Angela and Andy. And what is with the necking? Do you think this was standard for Angela? Or is it because she can't stomach Andy and she's just trying to get back at Dwight? I love this question. I thought that Angela went out with Andy as sort of a revenge date. She was very mad at Dwight. She really thought
为《朱诺》创作所有音乐的作曲家马特奥·梅西纳创作的。我喜欢这个。现在事情要变得尴尬了。安迪把德怀特拉到一边，寻求关于如何与安吉拉“一垒”的建议。他说他们一直在“脖子贴脖子”（necking），但这实际上意味着他们只是在摩擦脖子。根本没有接吻。为什么我们没有那段录像？我不知道。我不知道。安吉拉，我们有一个来自艾米·诺基的粉丝提问。她非常想知道你对安吉拉和安迪的背景故事是什么？还有那个“脖子贴脖子”是怎么回事？你认为这对安吉拉来说是标准的吗？还是因为她受不了安迪，只是想报复德怀特？我喜欢这个问题。我觉得安吉拉和安迪约会算是一种报复性约会。她当时非常生德怀特的气。她真的以为
she was done with Dwight. She was super, super angry with him. And as she started dating Andy, I think it became very clear to her that really Dwight had her heart, but she was too prideful to to admit that. So she tried to date Andy, but it was a chore. And I think the necking thing is just something she was doing to put him off. Like, how can I let him touch me, but not really touch me? So, yeah, I think her heart wasn't in it from the beginning. Yeah, I was thinking about it. And, you know, Angela can be very fussy and very structured, but we saw her going at it in Jim's little toy playhouse thing and email surveillance. So when she's into someone, it's not like she puts people through these weird paces of like, okay, first we just rub our necks together. I think this was
她和德怀特完了。她对他超级超级生气。当她开始和安迪约会时，我觉得她很清楚，其实德怀特拥有她的心，但她太骄傲了，不肯承认。所以她试着和安迪约会，但这是一种苦差事。我觉得“脖子贴脖子”只是她用来让他退缩的一种方式。就像，我怎么能让他碰我，但又不是真的碰我？所以，是的，我觉得她从一开始就没走心。是的，我一直在想。而且，你知道，安吉拉可以非常挑剔和刻板，但我们在《吉姆的玩具屋》和《电子邮件监控》里看到过她在那儿胡搞。所以当她喜欢某人时，她并不是那种会让人经历这些奇怪步骤的人，比如，好吧，首先我们只是摩擦脖子。我觉得这是
exclusive to Andy. Oh, yeah. Yeah. And maybe the senator too. Perhaps. I really think Dwight was the love of her life. And, you know, it just took them a while to get there. Poor Dwight, he's having to listen to all this. And he tries to put Andy off. He says, I don't think we should talk about this. People might overhear us. But then Andy just takes that to mean that they should come up with code names. Dwight's like, okay, well, Angela can stay the same, but let's change Andy to Dwight. Hmm. Okay. Yeah. And Andy's like, that's not really, that's not how this works. Lady, this really reminded me of how you and I tried to come up with code names when we would have conversations and we were afraid other people could overhear us.
安迪独有的。哦，是的。是的，也许还有参议员。也许吧。我真的认为德怀特是她一生的挚爱。而且，你知道，他们花了一段时间才走到一起。可怜的德怀特，他不得不听这一切。他试图让安迪退缩。他说，我不认为我们应该谈论这个。别人可能会偷听到。但安迪只是认为这意味着他们应该想出代号。德怀特说，好吧，安吉拉可以保持不变，但让我们把安迪改成德怀特。嗯。好吧。是的。安迪说，那不是，那不是这样运作的。女士，这真的让我想起你和我试图想出代号的时候，当我们进行谈话，又担心别人会偷听到我们。
And our code names were about this good. They were so obvious. It would be like a person's initials. So obvious. I know. We're not going to be spies, Jenna. We're not going to be spies, but we're going to be mom detectives solving small crimes. I would love to be a mom detective with you.
我们的代号也就这么好。它们太明显了。就像是一个人的名字缩写。太明显了。我知道。我们不会成为间谍，珍娜。我们不会成为间谍，但我们会成为解决小案件的妈妈侦探。我很乐意和你一起当妈妈侦探。
Mom detectives solving the small crimes no one cares about in your neighborhood. It's a hit. Who graffitied? The construction company. at the intersection. Exactly. We'll find out. We'll tell you.
妈妈侦探解决你社区里没人关心的那些小案件。这会很火。谁在十字路口的建筑公司涂鸦了？正是。我们会查出来的。我们会告诉你的。
We're on it. So coming up, we have a scene between Ryan and Michael that is so funny to me. When Michael calls him, you know, to gripe, first of all, he calls him Rye. Ryan is like, don't call me about small problems. What have I told you about that? Yeah. And he says, well, you don't like it when I call you about big problems either. So what do you want from me?
我们正在处理。接下来，我们有一个瑞安和迈克尔之间的场景，我觉得非常有趣。当迈克尔打电话给他，你知道，去抱怨时，首先，他叫他“黑麦”（Rye）。瑞安说，别因为小问题给我打电话。我跟你说过多少次了？是的。他说，好吧，我因为大问题给你打电话时你也不喜欢。那你到底想让我怎么样？
What do you want? So Jason said on the DVD commentary that, they shot this in real time. Now, Jenna, do you remember they had built a little office that was Ryan's office at corporate, right? Yes. So they had BJ, you know, on the other side of the soundstage in this little room with a camera with him. And then they had a camera with Steve in his office is Michael. And that's the room Jason sat in and they shot it simultaneously. And I think it really works because the chemistry is happening in real time. I always loved when we did that because it meant that you could improvise a little and the other person could react to you and you would get it
你想要什么？所以杰森在DVD评论中说，他们是实时拍摄的。现在，珍娜，你还记得他们建了一个小办公室，那是瑞安在总部的办公室，对吧？是的。所以他们让BJ，你知道，在摄影棚的另一边，在这个小房间里，带着摄像机和他在一起。然后他们让史蒂夫在办公室里带着摄像机，作为迈克尔。那就是杰森坐的房间，他们同时拍摄。我觉得这真的很有效，因为化学反应是实时发生的。我一直很喜欢我们那样做，因为这意味着你可以即兴发挥一点，对方可以对你做出反应，你可以在两台摄像机上都捕捉到。
on both cameras. Yes. And BJ said something I thought was so delightful because it's one of my favorite lines in this whole episode. BJ said he wrote the line, I can't cook and I'm starting a restaurant. And the restaurant he says he's going to start is Mike's cereal shack. It's going to have every cereal you can get in the store. Yeah. I want you to know, I did a little bit of a deep dive on Mike's cereal shack. I had to know. Has anyone opened a cereal shack? The answer is no, but a woman named Catherine has designed the most adorable vintage poster for Mike's cereal shack. She has a company on Etsy called Catbone Design. It's so, so cute. I'm going to put a picture of it in the pod. And then her profile really got me, Ange. Her profile says, I'm a stay-at-home. I'm a stay-at-home
是的。BJ说了一些我觉得非常令人愉快的话，因为这是我整集里最喜欢的台词之一。BJ说他写了那句台词，“我不会做饭，但我正在开一家餐馆。”他说他要开的餐馆是“迈克的麦片小屋”。它会有你在店里能买到的所有麦片。是的。我想让你知道，我深入研究了一下“迈克的麦片小屋”。我必须知道。有人开过麦片小屋吗？答案是没有，但一位名叫凯瑟琳的女士为“迈克的麦片小屋”设计了一张最可爱的复古海报。她在Etsy上有一家公司叫Catbone Design。太可爱了。我会把它的照片放到播客里。然后她的个人资料真的吸引了我，安吉。她的个人资料写着，我是一个全职妈妈，热衷于创造色彩缤纷和快乐的家。好的设计让我保持平衡，给我带来快乐。作为一名设计师，意味着我可以与他人分享这种快乐。珍娜和我分享了它。它太可爱了。我们要把它放到我们的故事里，伙计们，这样你们就可以看看她其他的艺术作品了。在继续之前，关于这个场景我还有一件事要说，瑞安的助理。是的。她在开头探头进门，说埃迪·墨菲在电话线上等你。是的。好吧，瑞安的助理是由弗吉尼亚·纽科姆扮演的。我得告诉你，她没有出演过《神探阿蒙》。我知道。
mom with a passion for creating colorful and happy homes. Good design keeps me balanced and brings me joy. And being a designer means I can share that joy with others. Jenna shared it with me. It is adorable. We're going to put it in our stories, you guys, so you can look at the rest of her art. There's one more thing I want to say about this scene before we move on, Ryan's assistant. Yes. She pokes her head in the door at the beginning and she says Eddie Murphy is on the line for you. Yes. Well, Ryan's assistant was played by Virginia Newcomb. And I'll have you know, she has not been on an episode of Monk. I know.
我也查了她是否出演过《神探阿蒙》。但她出演过《行尸走肉》。哦。所以没有交叉联系，但也许你从《行尸走肉》里认出了她。所以迈克尔说，你知道吗？广告商们，走开。我要自己做这件事。他要拿他的整个名誉去赌。
I look to see if she was on Monk, too. But she has been on The Walking Dead. Oh. So no crossover connection, but perhaps you recognize her from the Walking Dead. So Michael says, you know what? Ad guys, go away. I'm going to do this on my own. He's going to stake his whole reputation on it.
哦，是的。是的。他给大卫·华莱士打电话。是的。他说，听着，我要把它做出来。如果你不喜欢，没关系。我会把那些人叫回来，我自己掏钱。我需要这样做。好吧，他以整个通话开头，我不知道谁会这样和老板说话。我永远不会这样和老板说话。他说，嘿，是的，瑞安又在当小婊子了。瑞安说，
Oh, yeah. Yeah. He calls David Wallace. Yeah. And he says, listen, I'm going to make it. if you don't like it, fine. I'll bring those guys back and I'll pay for it on my own dime. I need to do this. Well, he leads off the whole call with, I don't know who talks to their boss like this. I would never talk to a boss like this. He's like, hey, yeah, Ryan's being a little bitch again. And Ryan goes,
我在通话中，迈克尔。他说，嘿，兄弟。这太尴尬了。我只是喜欢瑞安那种实事求是的态度。他从不因为迈克尔是迈克尔而感到慌乱，他对迈克尔非常直接和诚实，他之于迈克尔就像达里尔之于凯利。是的。只是直言不讳。我觉得他们两个都不知道该怎么处理。一点也不。这个和BJ的场景，作为瑞安，非常直接，让我想起了现实生活中的BJ。这是真的。他非常公平，但他会为你剖析，他会说，我不认为你应该那样做。原因如下，你知道吗？这就是我喜欢他的地方。我也是。坦率地说，每个人都需要那个不给你灌迷魂汤的朋友。你需要那个你可以打电话的朋友，而且你知道哪些朋友是哪些朋友。
I'm on the call, Michael. And he's like, hey, bro. Like, it's so awkward. I just love Ryan's matter-of-factness. He is never rattled by Michael being Michael, and he's so direct and honest with Michael, he is to Michael what Daryl is to Kelly. Yes. Just the straight truth. And I feel like neither one of them knows how to handle that. Not at all. This scene with BJ, as Ryan, just being very direct, reminded me the most of who BJ is in real life. It's true. And he's very fair, but he'll break it down for you, he'll be like, I don't think you should do that. And here's why, you know? And it's what I love about him. Me too. Everybody needs that friend who doesn't blow smoke up your ass, frankly. You need that person that you can call, and you know which friends are which friends.
你知道当你想要他们同意你时你会打给哪些朋友。然后你需要那个你可以打电话去听真话的朋友。对。BJ就是那个朋友。你可以打给他，但你必须准备好听到真正的答案。不是你想听的，而是你需要听的。是的。就像有那个告诉你牙齿上有西兰花的朋友一样。是的。你需要那个朋友。是的。关于这个电话场景，我有一个来自奥姆·帕特尔和米娜·霍伊特的粉丝发现。当大卫·华莱士和迈克尔通话时，摄像机不断扫向电话。起初，电话上的时间显示是9:38。但在通话结束时，时钟显示9:22。哦，那是个很好的发现。我想让你知道，时钟上的日期是
You know the friends you call when you want them to agree with you. And then you need that friend that you can call to get the straight truth. Right. And BJ is that friend. You can call him, but you have to be prepared to hear the real answer. Not what you want to hear, but what you need to hear. Yes. It's like having the friend that tells you the piece of broccoli's in your teeth. Yes. You need that friend. Yes. I have a little bit of a fan catch from this phone call scene coming in from Ome Patel and Mina Hoyt. When David Wallace and Michael are on the call, the camera keeps swishing down to the phone. At first, the time on the phone shows that it is 938. But at the end of the call, the clock shows 922. Oh, that's a good catch. I want you to know that the date on the
2007年10月3日。那就是我们拍摄这一集的时候。我认为那个时钟是他们拍摄这一集的真实时间。他们是在2007年10月3日早上9点左右拍摄的。我对此很确定。所以迈克尔正准备把大家召集到会议室，也许我们应该休息一下，然后回来深入了解他为大广告准备的大创意。他们面前有一场巨大的拍摄。全员出动。我知道。苏·格拉夫顿。苏·格拉夫顿。我们会回来的。好吧，我们回来了，大家都在会议室里。迈克尔正在进行一场关于每个人都很有创造力的动员演讲。不要让任何人告诉你你没有创造力。这引出了
clock says October 3rd, 2007. That is when we shot this episode. I think that clock is the real time they were shooting this episode. They shot it in the morning around 9 a.m. on October 3rd, 2007. I'm positive of that. So Michael's about to gather everyone in the conference room, maybe we should take a break, and then we'll come back and get into his big ideas for his big commercial. They have a huge shoot ahead of them. All hands on deck. I know. Sue Grafton. Sue Grafton. We'll be back. Okay, we are back and everyone is in the conference room. Michael is giving a big pep talk about how Everyone is creative. Don't let anyone tell you that you're not creative. And this leads
一系列的采访镜头。我想让你们知道，删减片段里还有更多。这一集里几乎每个人都有采访镜头，但并不是所有人都放进去了。所以现在迈克尔开始为这次大广告拍摄给人们分配工作。是的，他说，凯利，化妆，奥斯卡，服装设计。伙计们，去看10分4秒。奥斯卡直接对着镜头看，就在镜头里。这太棒了。当迈克尔说服装设计时，看看那一刻。然后他说，菲利斯，找个名人。是的。当我们走到办公区时，菲利斯得知神秘小说家苏·格拉夫顿正在斯坦镇购物中心进行签售。迈克尔说，去吧，菲利斯，去吧。你去把她找来。你劝她出演我们的广告，别接受“不”作为答案。他说，是的，这将是一个大政变。大政变。这时安迪试图通过问苏·格拉夫顿是否有吸引力来讨好安吉拉，
into a series of talking heads. And I want you guys to know there are even more in the deleted scenes. Pretty much every single person had a talking head in this episode, but not all of them made it in. So now Michael starts delegating jobs to people in preparation for this big commercial shoot. Yes, he says, Kelly, makeup, Oscar, costume design. Guys, go to 10 minutes, four seconds. Oscar shoots a look directly to camera right down the barrel. That is so great. When Michael says costume design, look at that moment. And then he says, Phyllis, get a celebrity. Yes. As we move out into the bullpen, this is when Phyllis learns that Sue Grafton, the mystery novelist, is at the Steentown Mall doing a book signing. And Michael says, go, Phyllis, go. You go get her. You convince her to be in our commercial and don't take no for an answer. He says, yeah, this will be a big coop. Big coop. This is when Andy is going to try to butter up Angela a little bit by asking if Sue Grafton is attractive,
克里德说，哦，是的，她超级火辣。安迪说，也许安吉拉应该在广告里假装是苏·格拉夫顿，因为安吉拉也超级火辣。是的，安吉拉说，那是不可能的。那是不可能的，因为正如你在采访镜头里透露的那样，你觉得神秘历史类型很恶心。而且你讨厌被挑逗。安吉拉，我们有一个来自克洛伊·M的粉丝提问。她想知道，你拍了多少次才说出那句台词？我讨厌被挑逗，而不笑场。克洛伊，我想他们用了唯一的一次。我想我只拍了一次没笑场的。我们当时笑得前仰后合。安吉拉·马丁就是太紧绷了。我光是说神秘
to which Creed says, oh, yeah, she's super hot. And Andy says maybe Angela should just pretend to be Sue Grafton in the commercial, since Angela is also super hot. Yeah, Angela's like, that's not going to happen. It's not going to happen because as you reveal in your talking head, you find the mystery, history genre disgusting. And you hate being titillated. Angela, we had a fan question from Chloe M. She would like to know, how many takes did it take for you to get out the line? I hate being titillated without laughing. Chloe, I think they used the only one. I think I only did one where I didn't laugh. We were cracking up. Angela Martin is just wired so tight. I laughed at just saying the mystery
类型很恶心就笑了。恶心。恶心。恶心。我喜欢安吉拉每次对随机主题有非常非常强烈的感受，比如这个。我确实有。好吧，你知道，我有一个没放进去的备用采访镜头。我想他们是在决定选哪一个。我绝对认为他们选了最好的一个。但我很想和你分享备用采访镜头是什么。它在删减片段里。
genre was disgusting. Disgusting. Disgusting. Disgusting. I love every time Angela has very, very strong feelings on random subjects, such as this. I do do. Well, you know, I had an alternate talking head that didn't make it in. I guess they were deciding between which one. I definitely think they picked the best one. But I want to share with you what the alternate talking head is. It's in the deleted scenes.
在这个删减的采访镜头里，安吉拉·马丁说，这不是我的第一个广告。我在高中时，在一家电子产品商店的广告里扮演了一个六岁的小孩。这太丢人了。我是说，我在高中时有多小？以至于我可以被当作六岁小孩。我喜欢这个。是谁让她这么做的？她有一个舞台妈妈吗？安吉拉·马丁有一个舞台妈妈吗？我不知道。你参加过选美比赛。对。我参加过选美比赛。现在我拍过广告？她的童年是什么样的？我们有一个来自杰伊·蒂克尔的粉丝提问。你们能谈谈你们拍过的任何广告吗？哦，杰伊。我拍过很多。那就是我如何养活自己的。我是1-800-牙医的接线员，我还拍过广告。当我搬到洛杉矶时，我唯一的人脉就是我的室友有一个广告经纪人。我确信我所要做的
In this deleted talking head, Angela Martin says, this is not my first commercial. When I was in high school, I played a six-year-old in an electronic store ad. and it was humiliating. I mean, how small was I in high school? That I could be passed for a six-year-old. I love it. And who made her do this? Did she have a stage mom? Did Angela Martin have a stage mom? I don't know. You did the pageants. Right. I did pageants. And now I did commercials? What was her childhood? We had a fan question from Jay Tickle. Can y'all talk about any commercials you've been in? Oh, Jay. I was in so many. That's how I, like, supported myself. I was an operator at 1,800 dentists. and I did commercials. When I moved to Los Angeles, my one connection that I had was that my roommate had a commercial agent. And I was convinced that all I had to do
就是把我的头像照给这个广告经纪人，这个人也会成为我的广告经纪人。那并没有发生。我花了大约两年时间才找到一个广告经纪人，然后我从来没有接到过一个广告。在有台词的角色里。从来没有，在我整个演员生涯中。我从来没有拍过广告。
was give this commercial agent my headshot and this person would also become my commercial agent. That did not happen. It took me about two years to find a commercial agent and then I never booked a single commercial. In a speaking role. ever in my whole career as an actress. I have never been in a commercial.
我拍过很多广告的背景。我做了很多背景工作。然后终于，大约一年前，斯米尔诺夫伏特加联系了我。要和泰德·丹森一起拍广告，我疯了。我妈妈太兴奋了。她说，珍娜，你终于要拍广告了。
I've been in the background of many commercials. I did a lot of background work. And then finally, about a year ago, I was approached by Smyrnaw Fodka. To be in a commercial with Ted Danson, I flipped out. My mom was so excited. She said, Jenna, you're finally going to be in a commercial.
20年后，终于接到了一个广告。詹妮弗，我喜欢你和泰德·丹森拍的那个广告。我觉得它太可爱了。我拍过很多广告。我拍过别克广告。哦，我拍过乐事Olestra。记得那种薯片吗？是的。你肛门渗漏了吗？没有，但袋子上写着。上面说它会导致肛门渗漏，但我整天都在吃那些薯片，伙计们，我玩得很开心。好吧，就是这样。那是史上最好的广告。我拍过诺德斯特龙的广告。我实际上找到了我以前的展示片。伙计们，当你们在这里作为广告演员时，你们会把所有的广告放在一个视频里，发给人们，就像一份视觉简历。我找到了它，珍娜。太棒了。我可能得把它放到《办公室女士》里。我们应该把我们早期的广告放进去。我只有我在电话广告背景里模糊的身影，侏罗纪公园游乐设施。我会放我的乐事Olestra广告，你放你的侏罗纪公园游乐设施。我们会把它放到故事里。我甚至不知道我还能不能找到它。我会找找看。好吧。我想他们把它从YouTube上删了。啊。太可惜了。
20 years later, finally booked a commercial. Jennifer, I loved that commercial you did with Ted Danson. I thought it was so stinking cute. I did a ton of commercials. I did a Buick spot. Oh, I did a Lays Olestra. Remember the potato chips? Yeah. Did you get anal leakage? No, but that was on the bag. It said it caused anal leakage, but I ate those chips all day, guys, and I was tot's fun. Well, there you go. That's the best commercial ever. I did a Nordstrom's commercial. I actually found my old sizzle reel. You guys, when you're out here as a commercial actor, you would put all your commercials on one, like, video to send out to people, like a visual resume. And I found it, Jenna. That's amazing. I might have to put it in office ladies. We should put our early commercials in there. All I have is me blurry in the background of a telephone commercial, the Jurassic Park ride. I'll put my Lays-Lestra spot and you put your Jurassic Park ride. We'll put it in the stories. I don't even know if I can find it anymore. I'll look for it. Okay. I think they took it down off YouTube. Aw. That's too bad.
那会是我们可以放进去的两个可爱的广告。安吉拉，我还有另一个粉丝提问，来自阿什利·斯内尔，她想知道，苏·格拉夫顿有没有在斯坦镇购物中心举办过签售会？阿什利，我查过了，据我所知，没有。她是一位真正的作家。她实际上是一位《纽约时报》畅销书作家。她最出名的是写了一系列以金西·米尔霍尼为主角的神秘小说。金西！
Those would be two cute ones that we could put in. I have another fan question, Angela, from Ashley Snell, who would like to know, has Sue Grafton ever held a book signing at the Steemptown Mall? Ashley, I looked it up, and from what I could find, no. She is a real author. She is a New York Times best-selling author, actually. She is best known for writing a series of mystery novels. starring a character named Kinsey Milhoney. Kinsey!
而且拼写和我的姓氏一模一样。是K-I-N-S-E-Y。那不是很疯狂吗？是的，我简直不敢相信。那是字母表神秘系列。金西·米尔霍尼是一位前警察转行的私家侦探。嗯。珍娜，我应该扮演金西·米尔霍尼吗？
And it's spelled exactly like my last name. It's K-I-N-S-E-Y. Isn't that crazy? Yeah, I couldn't believe it. It's the alphabet mystery series. Kinsey Milhoney was a former police officer-turned private investigator. Hmm. Jenna, should I play Kinsey Milhoney?
你绝对应该研究一下这个。我有一点额外的琐事。这不是《办公室》里第一次提到苏·格拉夫顿。回到《火灾》那一集，也是BJ·诺瓦克写的，迈克尔把斯坦利·卡普兰（一家制作备考材料公司的创始人）和苏·格拉夫顿搞混了。现在，我为此给BJ发了短信，因为我在想，BJ和苏·格拉夫顿有联系吗？我是说，BJ的父亲是一位著名的作家。我以为也许他的家人认识苏·格拉夫顿。但BJ说没有。他只是觉得这是一个非常有趣的引用。就是这样。好吧。我们必须谈谈达里尔为广告写的这段美妙的叮当声。是的。回到休息室，达里尔在键盘上，周围是安迪、凯文、克里德和凯利，都在唱这首本应出现在迈克尔广告里的歌。迈克尔走过来。他不喜欢它。他真的很希望他们能写一首说唱。
You should definitely look into this. I have a little bit of extra trivia. This is not the first time that there is a Sue Grafton reference on the office. Back on the fire, which was also written by B.J. Novak, Michael confuses Stanley Kaplan, who is the founder of a company that makes test prep materials with Sue Grafton. Now, I texted B.J. about this because I was thinking, does B.J. have a connection to Sue Grafton? I mean, B.J.'s father was a famous writer. I thought maybe his family knew Sue Grafton. But BJ said no. He just thought it was a really funny reference. There you go. All right. We have got to talk about this fantastic jingle that Daryl has written for the commercial. Yes. Back by the break room, we have Daryl on keyboard surrounded by Andy, Kevin, Creed, and Kelly, all singing this song that's meant to be in Michael's commercial. Michael comes up. He doesn't care for it. He was really hoping they were going to write a rap.
是的。达里尔说，什么是说唱？迈克尔说，哦，达里尔，我要给你做一个混音。达里尔说，是的，我很期待。是的。我们有一个来自凯莉·阿特金斯、温斯顿·F、罗布·霍兰德、艾丽莎·帕特森和马修·克鲁尔以及许多其他人的粉丝提问，他们想知道是谁写了这个叮当声。哦，我们有一些关于这个的好琐事，不是吗？是的。这个场景里的叮当声是BJ·诺瓦克的兄弟杰西·诺瓦克写的，他是一位专业作曲家。他还为《马男波杰克》和《明迪烦事多》做过配乐。他写了这个叮当声。这多有趣啊。他们把它留在了家里。太棒了。好吧，珍娜，现在吉姆无意中听到安迪告诉德怀特，他有一个关于“堕落天使行动”的更新。吉姆很担心德怀特，去找帕姆，你知道，要和她分享关于他的《第二人生》。伙计。是的，吉姆创建了自己的《第二人生》化身，因为他担心德怀特。是的。
Yeah. Darrell's like, what's a wrap? And Michael's like, oh, Darrell, I'm going to make you a mix. And Darrell's like, yeah, I am looking forward. Yeah. We had a fan question from Kaylee Adkins, Winston F, Rob Holland, Alyssa Patterson, and Matthew Krull, and many others who wanted to know who wrote this jingle. Ooh, we have some good trivia about that, don't we? Yes. The jingle in this scene was written by B.J. Novak's brother, Jesse Novak, who is a professional. professional composer. He's also done compositions for BoJack Horseman and the Mindy Project. He wrote this jingle. How fun is that? They kept it in the family. It's so great. Well, Jenna, now Jim overhears Andy telling Dwight, he has an update for him for Operation Fallen Angel. And Jim is worried about Dwight and goes over to Pam, you know, going to share with her about his second life. Like, dude. Yes, Jim has created his own second life avatar because he's worried about Dwight. Yes.
他给帕姆看，看它有多糟糕。我要带你进入《第二人生》。德怀特创建了《第二人生》的第二人生，这样他就可以更脱离现实。这时我们发现了关于吉姆的很多事情。关于吉姆，关于费城吉姆。是的。吉姆的化身背上背着一把吉他。记得吗，我们唯一看到的吉姆和吉他的迹象是《电子邮件监控》期间他房间里那把孤独的吉他。
And he shows Pam, look at how bad it is. I'm going to take you into second life. Dwight has created second, second life so that he can disconnect even more from reality. And this is when we find out a lot of things about Jim. About Jim, about Philly Jim. Yes. Jim's avatar has a guitar slung on his back. Remember, the only indication we've ever seen of Jim and guitar is that lone guitar in his room during email surveillance.
但我们从没见过他弹吉他。显然，吉姆希望他学会弹那把吉他。这是他《第二人生》化身的一部分。是的，我想它只是放在他房间的角落里，在积灰。甚至帕姆都说，什么？我不知道你会弹吉他。是的。关于这个，我们有很多粉丝提问，安吉拉。
But we never see him play guitar. Clearly, Jim wishes he had learned to play that guitar. It's part of his second life avatar. Yeah, I guess it just sits in the corner of his room and is collecting dust. And even Pam is like, what? I didn't know you play guitar. Yeah. We had a lot of fan questions about this, Angela.
玛丽亚·索萨、基亚娜·雷伯、奥特姆·贝克、娜塔莉·H和德丽莎·阿洛尼斯，他们说，我们发现吉姆的《第二人生》化身是费城的体育作家。他化身的工作是吉姆第九季工作的灵感来源吗？这是计划好的吗？我是说，没有，对吧？珍娜？这只是巧合吗？这是我的想法。我认为这一刻发生在这一集里，它进入了剧集圣经，这件小事，对吧？是的。然后后来，当需要写第九季时，你知道，那时我拿到了我的剧集圣经副本，约翰也拿到了。没错，因为你们是制片人，现在我记得你们是，比如，推销故事创意之类的。
Maria Sosa, Kiana Raber, Autumn Baker, Natalie H., and Delisa. Alonis, who said, we find out that Jim's second life avatar is a sports writer in Philly. Was his avatar's job the inspiration for Jim's season nine job? Was this planned? I mean, no, right? Jenna? Is it just by chance? Here's what I think. I think this moment happened in this episode and it went into the show Bible, this little bit of business, right? Yeah. And then later, when it came time to write season nine, you know, that's when I got my copy of the show Bible, and so did John. That's right, because you guys were producers, and now I remember you were part of, like, pitching, like, story ideas and stuff.
是的，约翰推销了吉姆去费城做这份体育工作的想法。所以我没有和他核实，但我必须想象，也许我在推测，剧集圣经里有那一小刻，他顺着它做了。但那是他的推销。当我们拍摄它时，它在这一刻并没有联系起来，但我认为它可能是这样发生的。是的，我觉得费城吉姆的种子已经种下了。费城吉姆。这里有一件疯狂的事。
Yes, and John pitched the idea that Jim would go off to Philly and have this sports job. So I didn't check with him, but I have to imagine that maybe I'm speculating, there was that little moment in the show Bible, and he ran with it. But that was his pitch. It was not connected in this moment when we shot it, but that's how I think it might have happened. Yeah, I think the seed had been planted for Philly Jim. Philly, Jim. And here's something crazy.
我们会讲到的，但我会在这里提一下。当他搬到费城时，他的公寓里有一把电吉他。哦！我不知道他是否学会了弹吉他，但费城吉姆和他的吉他，它们确实又出现了。我是说，这一切都是有关联的，伙计们。我确信。现在在12分52秒，伙计们，达里尔和他的团队继续排练。他们有了一首新主题曲，因为，你知道，迈克尔给了他们笔记，对吧？
We'll get to it, but I'll bring it up here. When he does move to Philly, there's an electric guitar in his apartment. Oh! I don't know if he ever learns to play the guitar, but Philly Jim and his guitar, they do show up again. I mean, it was all connected, you guys. I'm convinced. Now at 12 minutes, 52 seconds, you guys, Daryl and his team are continuing to rehearse. They've got a new theme song because, you know, Michael gave them notes, right?
所以现在他们写了一首新歌。猜猜是谁写了这个版本？告诉我们，安吉。克雷格·罗宾逊。是的。当然，我们知道克雷格是一位了不起的音乐家。哦，是的。克雷格太棒了。
So now they've written a new song. And guess who wrote this version? Tell us, Ange. Craig Robinson. Yes. And of course, we knew that Craig was an amazing musician. Oh, yeah. Craig is fantastic.
他，比如，巡演什么的。他很棒。在DVD评论中，他们分享说编剧室里有一场关于他们应该使用哪首叮当声的激烈辩论，他们最终是，房间里分成了两派。他们都喜欢。所以他们想办法把它们都放进了这一集里，我觉得这很棒。太有趣了。是的，BJ告诉我这很酷，因为它建立了一个迈克尔非常强迫症的想法，他一直让他们写新版本的歌。这一幕里有一句迈克尔的台词我非常喜欢。他说，我讨厌它。我不讨厌它。我只是根本不喜欢它。太糟糕了。
He, like, tours and everything. He's great. In the DVD commentary, they shared that there was a heated debate in the writer. room about which jingle they should use, and they ultimately were like, the room was divided. They loved them both. So they found a way to have them both in the episode, which I thought was great. So fun. Yeah, BJ told me it was cool because it set up this idea that Michael was really obsessive, and he kept making them write new versions of the song. There's a line from this scene that I love from Michael. He says, I hate it. I don't hate it. I just don't like it at all. It's terrible.
我非常喜欢那句台词。关于克雷格在评论中谈到的另一件事，我想和你们分享的是，他只有一小时的时间和那些人排练。他说他们立刻就掌握了，立刻，它就自然而然地到位了。除了也许一个时刻。我们有一个粉丝发现。雷切尔和杰里米写信说，在13分15秒，埃德开始在错误的时间唱歌，然后他差点笑场。这是最好的。女士，让我们去停车场。
I love that light so much. One other thing I'm going to share with you that Craig talks about on the commentary is that he only had an hour to rehearse with those guys. And he said they got it right away, right away, it just fell into place. Except for maybe one moment. We had a fan catch. Rachel and Jeremy wrote in to say, at 13 minutes, 15 seconds, Ed starts to sing at the wrong time and then he almost breaks. It's the best. Lady, let's move to the parking lot.
迈克尔真的对人们失去了耐心。是的，好吧，他说，你知道，这是一个关键场景。如果他们不明白，整个事情就会分崩离析。是的，安迪穿着某种跑步装备。他们没走多远，因为菲利斯从购物中心回来了。她在啜泣。她被彻底摧毁了。她被摧毁了。
Michael is really losing his patience with people. Yeah, well, he says, you know, this is a pivotal scene. If they don't get it, the whole thing will fall apart. Yeah, Andy is dressed in some sort of running gear. They don't get very far because Phyllis comes back from the mall. She is sobbing. She is so gutted. She is gutted.
她在朋友面前被赶出了购物中心。我想她所有的朋友都喜欢苏·格拉夫顿。他们都在那里要签名。菲利斯就是不接受“不”作为答案，因为迈克尔告诉她，别接受“不”作为答案。把苏·格拉夫顿带到这里来。她一直缠着她，他们就把她赶走了。在这个场景的最后，有一个很棒的小标签，凯文给了菲利斯一张胶带代替纸巾。我们收到了一些关于它的邮件。安吉拉，来自温斯顿·F和德琳娜·德拉诺，他们想知道这个片段是即兴创作的还是写好的。我为此给布莱恩发了短信。因为我没有第四季的剧本。我猜
She got kicked out of the mall in front of her friends. All of her friends, I guess, love. Sue Grafton. They were all there for autographs. And Phyllis just wouldn't take no for an answer because Michael told her, don't take no for an answer. Get Sue Grafton here. And she kept bugging her and they kicked her out. At the very end of this scene, there is a great little tag where Kevin offers Phyllis a piece of tape in lieu of a tissue. We got some mail about it. Angela from Winston F. and Delina Delano, they wanted to know if this bit was improvised. or scripted. I texted Brian about it. Because I don't have the scripts for season four. I'm going to guess
它是即兴创作的。这看起来非常像布莱恩会即兴发挥的东西。你是对的。他告诉我，最初这一幕是以摄像机仅仅停留在菲利斯哭泣上结束的。他实际上被安排在离背景更远一点的地方，和凯特在一起。他们还在处理那个小跑步场景。但他有一个想法，在最后走过去，递给她一张胶带作为纸巾。好吧，他们喜欢它。所以下一次他们做这个场景时，他们实际上把他拉得更靠前了一点，他们给了史蒂夫那句台词，“有人给她一张纸巾”。然后他撕下一块胶带，那成了这一幕的结尾。太棒了。太完美了。这是一个很好的例子，说明我们的即兴创作是如何融入场景的。我们会做它们。然后如果他们喜欢
it was improvised. That seems very much like something Brian would improvise. You are correct. He told me that originally the scene had ended with the camera just lingering on Phyllis crying. And he was actually placed a little further in the background with Kate. They were still kind of working on the little running scene. But he had the idea at the end to walk up and offer her a piece of tape. as a tissue. Well, they loved it. So the next time they did the scene, they actually pulled him a little bit more into the foreground and they gave Steve the line, someone give her a tissue. And then he tore off the piece of tape and that became the button of the scene. It's so great. It's perfect. That's such a great example of how our improvisations would work into a scene. We would do them. And then if they liked
它们，他们会说，好吧，让我们以一种创造有趣结尾或创造有趣时刻的方式把你拉进来。我还想指出，我想我能看到菲利斯快要笑场了。她看起来简直快要笑出来了。我不知道怎么说才不会听起来很奇怪，但我喜欢菲利斯这个角色每次哭泣的时候。为什么？为什么它这么好笑。她非常擅长演绎那些情感节奏，我只是爱她。我也爱它。我真的很爱它。珍娜，帕姆在她的办公桌前工作得非常努力，14分49秒。这个邓德·米夫林标志，她真的把她的心和灵魂投入进去了。我很钦佩她。我认为这是成功的关键。无论项目有多大或多小，无论你是否得到报酬，当你是一个挣扎的艺术家时，你必须
them, they would say, okay, well, let's draw you into this in a way that that creates a fun button or creates a fun moment. I also want to point out, I think I can see Phyllis about to break. She looks like she is literally about to laugh. I don't know how to say this without it sounding weird, but I love every time the character of Phyllis is crying. Why? Why is it so funny. She's just so good at playing those emotional beats and I just love her. I love it too. I really love it. Jenna, Pam is working so hard at her desk, 14 minutes 49 seconds. This Dunder Mifflin logo, she is just really putting her heart and soul into it. I admire her. I think this is the key to success. It doesn't matter how big or small the project, if you're getting paid or not getting paid, when you're a struggling artist, you have to
他们会说，好吧，那我们把你拉进来，用一种能制造出有趣按钮或有趣瞬间的方式。我还想指出，我觉得我看到菲利斯快要破功了。她看起来简直快要笑出来了。我不知道怎么说才不会听起来很奇怪，但我每次看到菲利斯这个角色哭的时候都特别喜欢。为什么？为什么那么好笑？她真的太擅长演绎那些情感节奏了，我就是很喜欢她。我也很喜欢。我真的很喜欢。珍娜，帕姆在她的办公桌前工作得非常努力，14分49秒。这个邓德·米夫林标志，她真的是全身心地投入其中。我很佩服她。我认为这就是成功的关键。无论项目大小，无论你是否得到报酬，当你是一个挣扎中的艺术家时，你必须
every project you're all. She has to treat this as if it's going in a Martin Scorsese film, and she is, and I think she's right on. Yes, and so much so that she doesn't go home. Jim's like, are you coming? And she's like, no, I'm going to stay. I have a question. Is this a little hint that they're living together? Interesting. I never thought they were living together, but I think they're in that phase of their relationship where they're staying over at each other's places a lot. Like they might as well be living together, but I they don't think they are yet. Okay. Well, poor Jim has to ride home now with Meredith. He does. And then Pam, we reveal, has slept in the office overnight. And then the next morning opens with Pam
每一个项目你都是。她必须把这当作是要拍进马丁·斯科塞斯的电影里一样对待，她确实也是这么做的，我觉得她做得非常对。是的，甚至到了她都不回家的地步。吉姆问，你要一起走吗？她说，不，我要留下来。我有个问题。这算不算暗示他们住在一起了？有趣。我从来没觉得他们住在一起，但我认为他们正处于那种经常在对方家里过夜的关系阶段。就像他们住在一起也没什么两样，但我认为他们还没到那一步。好吧。好吧，可怜的吉姆现在得载梅雷迪斯回家了。确实。然后我们发现，帕姆在办公室过了一夜。第二天早上，帕姆
waking up to a phone call from Jim. He got her breakfast. He got her breakfast. And in the commentary, they said there was a big debate in the writer's room about, does he bring her orange juice or coffee? I don't remember seeing either on the desk. There's a cup of orange juice and what looks like some kind of breakfast maybe sandwich. Yeah, I'm guessing it's from McDonald's because Jim says that Creed ate the hash browns. Yes, but they felt like orange juice was just a sweeter token than coffee. That's what they decided. But no detail went unturned, you guys.
在吉姆的电话中醒来。他给她买了早餐。他给她买了早餐。在评论音轨里，他们说编剧室里有过一场大争论，关于他到底是带了橙汁还是咖啡？我不记得桌上有这两样东西。有一个杯子装着橙汁，还有看起来像某种早餐三明治的东西。是的，我猜是麦当劳的，因为吉姆说克里德吃了薯饼。是的，但他们觉得橙汁比咖啡更贴心。这就是他们决定的。但是，伙计们，每一个细节都没有被放过。
This is the point that there was a whole conversation about should there be orange juice or coffee. That's how much thought was put into all of these moments. Well, you know, Pam does not regularly drink coffee. You know, she drinks tea. So I think orange juice was the right choice. Yeah. Well, Pam explains in a talking head that she worked until 2.45 a.m. And then she had to decide between spending the night with Michael and Dwight in the office or risk
这就是为什么会有关于该选橙汁还是咖啡的完整讨论。这就是在这些时刻投入的心思。嗯，你知道，帕姆平时不喝咖啡。你知道，她喝茶。所以我认为橙汁是正确的选择。是的。好吧，帕姆在采访中解释说她工作到凌晨2点45分。然后她必须在和迈克尔、德怀特一起在办公室过夜，还是冒着
driving home and falling asleep at the wheel and dying in a fiery car wreck. She passed out on her keyboard trying to decide. So this was the talking head with Jason that I could not get. through. I could not get through that last line. I passed out on my keyboard trying to decide because there's this little pause. And in that pause, the anticipation of that last line would make us laugh. This is something you guys should all know. I have found over the years, and I think Jenna, you'll agree with me, it's the pauses in comedy that get you almost more than the line. When Steve would pause before saying something ridiculous as Michael, it was that three second
开车回家时在方向盘上睡着并死于火灾车祸的风险之间做出选择。她在做决定时在键盘上睡着了。所以这就是我和杰森的那段采访，我一直没能录完。我没法录完最后那句台词。我在做决定时在键盘上睡着了，因为中间有那么一点停顿。而在那个停顿中，对最后那句台词的期待会让我们发笑。这是你们都应该知道的一点。多年来我发现，我想珍娜你会同意我的，喜剧中的停顿比台词本身更能打动你。当史蒂夫在作为迈克尔说出荒谬的话之前停顿时，那三秒钟的
pause that would have us all on the floor. It was like this collective moment where we all knew what was coming and we couldn't bear it. A hundred percent. I have a catch. Okay. In an upcoming episode, it is going to be revealed that Pam wears glasses. Remember because she's going to have to wear her spare pair to work. Right. Does that mean that Pam just slept in her contacts? Can you do that? I don't wear contacts, but I think you're not supposed to do that. I think that's a big no-no. I think it dries your eyeballs out or something. I mean, also, like, does Pam keep a toothbrush and toothpaste in her desk? I thought the same thing. And finally, before we move on from this little moment, what has Dwight done to the couch? He turned it on its side, and then he has taken all the cushions off,
停顿会让我们所有人都笑翻在地。那就像是一个集体的时刻，我们都知道接下来会发生什么，我们简直无法承受。百分之百。我有一个发现。好的。在接下来的一集中，将会揭露帕姆戴眼镜。记得吗，因为她不得不戴备用眼镜去上班。对。那是不是意味着帕姆只是戴着隐形眼镜睡觉了？可以那样做吗？我不戴隐形眼镜，但我认为你不应该那样做。我觉得那是大忌。我想那会弄干你的眼球之类的。我的意思是，还有，帕姆在办公桌里放了牙刷和牙膏吗？我也这么想。最后，在我们离开这个小插曲之前，德怀特对沙发做了什么？他把它侧放了，然后把所有的垫子都拿掉了，
and he is sleeping under the cushions. It's so odd. I think he got cold, and he was trying to make a cushion blanket. I guess it's very strange. I feel like he's done it before. He has a system for that couch. What we know now, Angela, is probably that Dwight, Pam, and Michael all have really bad breath because I can't imagine any of them had toothbrushes. No. Maybe Michael, though. I feel like maybe Michael keeps one in his cabinet.
他睡在垫子下面。太奇怪了。我想他冷了，他试图做一个垫子毯子。我猜这非常奇怪。我觉得他以前肯定做过。他有一套关于那张沙发的系统。安吉拉，我们现在知道的是，德怀特、帕姆和迈克尔的口气肯定都很重，因为我无法想象他们谁带了牙刷。不。也许迈克尔带了。我觉得迈克尔可能在柜子里放了一把。
So he's got fresh breath. But, I mean... My guess is Michael has a whole change of clothes in that cabinet. He's got some boxer shorts, a pair of socks. Yeah. He's prepared. Should we move into the break? grim because Andy has some news for Dwight. Oh, Operation Fallen Angel turned a corner. I guess while
所以他的口气很清新。但是，我的意思是……我猜迈克尔在那个柜子里放了一整套换洗衣服。他有平角短裤，一双袜子。是的。他准备得很充分。我们要进入休息时间了吗？很严峻，因为安迪有消息要告诉德怀特。哦，堕落天使行动有了转机。我猜当
they were doing their form of necking, he's kissing her earlobe and she says, O.D. Dwight's face lights up. Andy thinks that this is because of his name, Andy, but we all know the truth. Andy, what a stretch. Why would she single out one letter of your name? Oh, A. O-N. O-D. Oh, Y. Yeah. But Dwight then has this very fun moment where he is rejoicing with Andy over Angela calling out O-D. There's hope, Dwight. I love the next scene. Michael sends the commercial to corporate. He's like, they'll probably watch it right away. I know I would. Yeah. And he's like, I'm not going to call him. I'm not going to bug him. And then he calls him 10 seconds later. I know it's perfect. We've all. in there. Yeah. We've all sent somebody, something we've written, something you've worked on.
他们进行那种亲热时，他在亲吻她的耳垂，她说，O.D.。德怀特的脸亮了起来。安迪认为这是因为他的名字，安迪，但我们都知道真相。安迪，真是牵强。她为什么要挑出你名字里的一个字母？哦，A。O-N。O-D。哦，Y。是的。但德怀特随后有一个非常有趣的时刻，他和安迪一起为安吉拉喊出O.D.而欢呼。有希望了，德怀特。我喜欢下一场戏。迈克尔把广告发给了总公司。他说，他们可能会马上看。我知道我会的。是的。他说，我不会打电话给他们。我不会去烦他们。然后他10秒后就打了电话。我知道，太完美了。我们都经历过。是的。我们都给别人发过我们写的东西，我们努力工作的东西。
And then you just wait and wait. And then you do that thing in your head where you're like, oh my gosh, what if my email was down? Yeah. What if they never got it? Oh, I should call them. I should text them and just nudge them. Yeah. Ten days later. And this was a big deal. This kind of time jump. We hadn't done in the show before. It's very strange. They had that little bit of an unwritten rule that the ideal episode happened over one day. Yeah. We didn't always keep to it, but for the most part, our episodes happened in one day. So this says 10 days later. It didn't bump me, Jenna.
然后你就等着，等着。然后你在脑子里做那种事，你会想，天哪，如果我的邮件没发出去怎么办？是的。如果他们没收到怎么办？哦，我应该给他们打电话。我应该发短信给他们，提醒他们一下。是的。十天后。这可是件大事。这种时间跳跃。我们在剧中以前没做过。非常奇怪。他们有一个不成文的小规定，理想的一集发生在一周内。是的。我们并不总是遵守，但大部分情况下，我们的剧集发生在一周内。所以这写着十天后。这并没有让我感到突兀，珍娜。
No. I was fine with it. And Michael is saying, well, welcome to the world premiere of the corporate crap fest. Yeah. They did not pick his commercial. They did not. The whole gang has gathered at poor Richard's pub to watch the corporate crap fest. Yeah. Yeah. They watch it. They're delighted. They are in the last five seconds.
不。我没问题。迈克尔说，欢迎来到公司烂片节的世界首映。是的。他们没有选他的广告。他们没有。整群人都聚集在理查德酒吧观看公司烂片节。是的。是的。他们看了。他们很高兴。他们在最后五秒钟。
It's the same commercial as the National Branch, but this time it ends with everyone at Dunder-Mifflin-Sgrantan waving. On the roof. On the roof. I guess that was Michael's big creative contribution is we'll wave from the roof. Yeah, we won't be in the parking lot. We're going to go on the rooftop. Jenna, do you remember I wasn't there that day?
这和国家分部的广告一样，但这次结尾是邓德·米夫林斯克兰顿的所有人在挥手。在屋顶上。在屋顶上。我猜那是迈克尔最大的创意贡献，就是我们在屋顶上挥手。是的，我们不会在停车场。我们要去屋顶上。珍娜，你记得那天我不在吗？
No. I know. Mindy and I both were not there that day. We had to be superimposed in. we never went up on the roof. We just did a wave. They sort of cheated it in the parking lot. And then they did a little fancy editing and put us in the shot. That is crazy because I did look specifically to see if everyone was in there and you're there. But if you look closely and I screen grabbed it, Mindy and I are kind of awkwardly off to the side. Do you see the gap? That is crazy. That's like
不。我知道。那天明迪和我都不在。我们必须被后期合成进去。我们从来没上过屋顶。我们只是挥了挥手。他们在停车场里作弊拍了一下。然后他们做了一些花哨的剪辑，把我们放进了镜头里。这太疯狂了，因为我确实专门看了看每个人是否都在里面，而你确实在里面。但如果你仔细看，我截了图，明迪和我有点尴尬地站在一边。你看到那个空隙了吗？太疯狂了。那就像
that crazy thing they do when someone has to play their own twin. Exactly. Well, you can see it at 18 minutes, 10 seconds. And I know why I couldn't be there that day. I can't remember why Mindy couldn't be there. But I had one of my first OB-GYN appointments because I was pregnant. Lady, I was wondering if you were going to share that in this episode because I just want you to know, I can see, I'm getting goosebumps. I can see your glow. Really? In this whole episode, yes, I clocked it the minute I put this episode on. I was like, oh my gosh, this is the episode where Angela was pregnant. Yes. And I had this appointment.
当某人必须扮演自己的双胞胎时做的那些疯狂的事。没错。好吧，你可以在18分10秒看到。我知道那天我为什么不能去。我不记得明迪为什么不能去。但我有第一次妇产科预约，因为我怀孕了。天哪，我一直在想你是否会在这一集里分享这个，因为我想让你知道，我能看到，我起鸡皮疙瘩了。我能看到你的光彩。真的吗？在这一整集里，是的，我一打开这一集就注意到了。我想，天哪，这就是安吉拉怀孕的那一集。是的，我有这个预约。
I guess I couldn't move it. And, you know, Kent was really sweet. He was like, oh, it's fine, Angela. Well, don't worry about it. Go to your appointment. Yeah, that's why I wasn't in it. Well, I'll never forget, Angela, because you told me you were pregnant in my trailer at work. Yes.
我想我没法改期。而且，你知道，肯特真的很贴心。他说，哦，没关系，安吉拉。别担心。去你的预约吧。是的，这就是我为什么没在里面的原因。好吧，我永远不会忘记，安吉拉，因为你在工作时的拖车里告诉我你怀孕了。是的。
This is one of my favorite moments of our whole friendship. We were in Jenna's trailer having lunch as we often did, and you were telling me a whole story. I think it was about your cat. Is it about your cat? Lady, I remember I was done with lunch. You were still eating, and I was doing these little five-pound weights, little bicep curls. Yes, you were telling me a whole story while lifting weights. You're very passionate.
这是我们整个友谊中最喜欢的时刻之一。我们像往常一样在珍娜的拖车里吃午饭，你正在给我讲一个完整的故事。我想是关于你的猫的。是关于你的猫吗？天哪，我记得我吃完午饭了。你还在吃，我正在做这些五磅重的小哑铃，做二头肌弯举。是的，你一边举重一边给我讲了一个完整的故事。你非常有激情。
I'll never forget it because I go on and on and on. I'm pumping my arms, and then I get finished, and you say, well, I have some news. I'm pregnant. And I just dropped the weights, and I screamed. And our AD came over to the trailer because I think they thought someone had had an accident. There was this huge thud followed by a scream. And then you said to me, and why didn't you interrupt me? I'm just rambling on about nothing.
我永远不会忘记它，因为我一直在说个不停。我挥舞着手臂，然后我做完了，你说，嗯，我有个消息。我怀孕了。我直接扔掉了哑铃，尖叫了起来。我们的助理导演跑到了拖车旁，因为我想他们以为有人出了事故。先是一声巨响，接着是一声尖叫。然后你对我说，你为什么不打断我？我只是在胡言乱语。
And you're sitting on this big piece of information. Why did you let me go on and on? And I said, well, I wanted to hear your story. My God, so funny. I was just so happy for you. I knew how much you wanted to be a mother. And I could just, I'm tearing up right now thinking about it because you are such a good mother. You are a born nurturer.
你坐拥这么大的信息。你为什么让我一直说个不停？我说，嗯，我想听你的故事。天哪，太搞笑了。我只是为你感到高兴。我知道你有多想成为一名母亲。我现在想到这里都要流泪了，因为你是一个如此好的母亲。你是一个天生的养育者。
And I was just so happy for you. I knew how much you wanted that. But yes, when I watched this episode, I knew right away. Oh, this is the one. And I didn't know if you were going to share it or not, so I waited. Yes, I was never up on the roof. Never. Never in the whole series. Wow. I know. Your old hat at being up on the roof. Oh, man. So Jim does a very sweet thing. He asks the bartender if he will play their commercial, the one that they all made together. He hands him the disc. And Michael is so moved by this. Yeah. Well, you know, the bartender slash waiter guy was played by Drew Powell. you guys might recognize him from Gotham. He's a regular on Gotham. He also played Eddie Murdoch from the Monk episode. Mr. Monk can't see a thing. And here's my crossover connection with Drew. Drew and I played husband and wife in a lifetime movie called Terror in the Woods. Oh, I remember this. Yes, we filmed it in Atlanta. And so we hung out and spent some time together. And when I got back to L.A., we realized our kids were at the same elementary school.
我只是为你感到高兴。我知道你有多渴望那个。但是是的，当我观看这一集时，我立刻就知道了。哦，就是这一集。我不知道你会不会分享它，所以我等着。是的，我从来没上过屋顶。从来没有。整个系列里都没有。哇。我知道。你可是上屋顶的老手了。哦，天哪。所以吉姆做了一件非常贴心的事。他问酒保是否可以播放他们的广告，他们一起制作的那一个。他把光盘递给了他。迈克尔对此非常感动。是的。好吧，你知道，酒保兼服务员是由德鲁·鲍威尔扮演的。你们可能从《哥谭》里认出他。他是《哥谭》的常驻演员。他还扮演了《神探阿蒙》那一集里的埃迪·默多克。阿蒙先生什么也看不见。这是我和德鲁的交叉联系。德鲁和我在一部名为《林中恐怖》的终身电影中扮演夫妻。哦，我记得这个。是的，我们在亚特兰大拍摄的。所以我们在一起玩，花了一些时间。当我回到洛杉矶时，我们意识到我们的孩子在同一所小学。
You're kidding me. No, our sons went to elementary school together. And then I started seeing him at morning assembly meetings and all kinds of stuff. That's so crazy. I know. What a small world. So everybody watches Michael's version of the commercial. And it's so charming.
你在开玩笑吧。不，我们的儿子一起上小学。然后我开始在早晨的集会上看到他，还有各种各样的事情。太疯狂了。我知道。世界真小。所以每个人都看了迈克尔版本的广告。非常迷人。
Everyone reacts really well to it. And there was a decision to be made as to whether or not when we watch Michael's commercial, we were going to be kind of embarrassed and like, oh, Michael. Or if we were all going to love it. And Jason talked about this. It was really important to him that they pick the sweeter ending. Here's what he had to say. There was an opportunity for a tender ending.
每个人对它的反应都很好。当时有一个决定要做，就是当我们看迈克尔的广告时，我们是会感到尴尬，比如，哦，迈克尔。还是我们都会喜欢它。杰森谈到了这一点。对他来说，选择更甜蜜的结局真的很重要。这是他要说的。有一个温柔结局的机会。
And I got the sense that the writing staff of the office was hesitant to do too many of those. That there's this kind of traditional television episode where it's funny throughout, it has opportunity for satire. And then towards the end, you have some sort of tender denouement, and that they didn't want to be doing this every time. but I really wanted that for this spot. I really wanted the episode to end in a bar where the cast is watching the commercial together and they bond over it. And there's something really lovely
我感觉到《办公室》的编剧团队对做太多这种事情感到犹豫。有一种传统的电视剧集，它通篇都很搞笑，有讽刺的机会。然后在结尾处，你会有一种温柔的结局，他们不想每次都这样做。但我真的很想要这个片段。我真的很想让这一集在酒吧里结束，演员们一起看广告，他们因此建立了联系。有一些非常可爱的东西
about people who come together to make something. That was really important to me because that's an idea I know really well. I think anyone who's ever done a high school play or made a high school video or done anything creative knows what it feels like when outsiders come together to make something. And no matter how it turns out,
关于人们聚在一起创造东西。这对我来说真的很重要，因为那是一个我非常熟悉的想法。我想任何做过高中戏剧、拍过高中视频或做过任何创造性工作的人都知道，当外人聚在一起创造东西时的感觉。无论结果如何，
the collective process of creating something, something is just wonderful and bonds you and erases fights because you can't help it but come together and make something. And that's what the end of that episode felt like. I remember everyone just standing in the bar watching the episode and we aired the actually, you know, we played back the actual thing. It was just so lovely. And I remember seeing a cut of the episode for the first time. And again, watching an edit of the episode was much like directing it. These guys knew what they were doing, you know? I don't think I had any notes. I just kind of watched an office episode that I happened to have a directing credit on and has a slightly emotional ending. And I'm
创造东西的集体过程，本身就是美妙的，它会让你建立联系并消除争吵，因为你无法抗拒聚在一起创造东西。这就是那一集结尾的感觉。我记得每个人都站在酒吧里看那一集，我们播出了实际上，你知道，我们回放了实际的东西。真是太可爱了。我记得第一次看到这一集的剪辑。同样，观看这一集的剪辑就像导演它一样。这些人知道他们在做什么，你知道吗？我想我没有任何意见。我只是看了一集我恰好有导演署名的《办公室》，而且有一个稍微感人的结局。我
really proud and I'm really grateful that the writing staff was up for that at the end of the day because it makes me cherish the episode even more. I love it too. Oh my gosh. Yeah, I couldn't imagine it any other way. I mean, this was such a big collective project that everyone came together for. I feel like everyone in the office would have had some kind of personal interest in it. And I'm so glad we were happy and reacted that way. I have a confession. What? The very beginning of the commercial, it starts with a woman's hand taking a piece of paper off of the copier. Yeah. That is supposed to be me. That's supposed to be Pam. But I wasn't there that day. I don't know why. I was not pregnant, everybody. For whatever reason, they put Pam's watch and Pam's sweater on someone else. I don't know. I
真的很自豪，也很感激编剧团队最终能接受这一点，因为它让我更加珍惜这一集。我也很喜欢。天哪。是的，我无法想象其他任何方式。我的意思是，这是一个如此大的集体项目，每个人都参与其中。我觉得办公室里的每个人都会对此有某种个人兴趣。我很高兴我们很开心并做出了那样的反应。我有一个坦白。什么？广告的最开始，是一个女人的手从复印机上拿走一张纸。是的。那应该是我的手。那应该是帕姆。但我那天不在。我不知道为什么。我没有怀孕，各位。不管什么原因，他们把帕姆的手表和帕姆的毛衣穿在了别人身上。我不知道。我
kind of feel like it was one of our AEDs or one of our PAs. So that is not my hand at the top. I did not know that. I am not in this either. One of the things, Jason, said in the commentary about it that I loved is that he said filming this really reminded him of home movies he would make with his dad. His dad is Ivan Reitman, an amazing director. Jason said when he was a kid, he had a little handheld camera, you know, and he would make these videos like the paper airplane like that, all of that with his dad. And it really reminded him of that. And that's, in fact, how they shot. They shot with just a little handheld. It's funny you mentioned the paper airplane because we had a fan question from Grant Pickle, who said, how did you get the shot of the paper airplane?
觉得那可能是我们的助理导演或制片助理之一。所以那不是我的手。我不知道这一点。我也不在里面。杰森在评论音轨里说的一件事我非常喜欢，他说拍摄这个真的让他想起了他和他爸爸拍的家庭电影。他爸爸是伊万·雷特曼，一位了不起的导演。杰森说当他还是个孩子的时候，他有一个小手持摄像机，你知道，他会和爸爸一起拍这些视频，比如纸飞机之类的。这真的让他想起了那个。事实上，他们就是那样拍摄的。他们只是用一个小手持摄像机拍摄。你提到纸飞机很有趣，因为我们有一个来自格兰特·皮克尔的粉丝问题，他说，你是怎么拍到纸飞机的镜头的？
Well, guys, they just taped it to the front of this little handheld camera. And Jason talked about the inspiration behind that shot. Sam, will you play that clip? There was a shot that really became popular in the 90s, and you saw it in like Sam Ramey films and John Wu films. I associate it with Evil Dead 2, an Army of Darkness, but also would. have been popular in like literally any John Wu film where you like follow a bullet, you know, where it looks like the camera is riding on the back of a bullet or an arrow or something like that. And I could have just imagined, you know, Michael Scott seeing any one of these films,
好吧，伙计们，他们只是把它粘在这个小手持摄像机的正面。杰森谈到了那个镜头背后的灵感。萨姆，你能播放那个片段吗？有一个镜头在90年代变得非常流行，你在像萨姆·雷米的电影和吴宇森的电影里都能看到。我把它和《鬼玩人2》和《黑暗军团》联系在一起，但也可能在任何吴宇森的电影里都很流行，比如你跟随一颗子弹，你知道，看起来摄像机骑在子弹或箭之类的东西后面。我简直可以想象，你知道，迈克尔·斯科特看了这些电影中的任何一部，
you know, Mission Impossible 2 or like Broken Arrow or, you know, I don't know. I don't know if Michael Scott watches the old Hong Kong films. But maybe he just saw like Van Dam and Hard Target and was like, we need to do a camera attached to the paper airplane shot. And again, this is my favorite kind of thing. It would be kind of great to make an entire movie that way. I love how much thought went into this commercial. It's so perfect. Yeah. We end this episode with a little tag. It's Andy's talking head. He's still trying to figure out the end of the Kid Cat jingle. He cannot figure it out. And he struggles with it throughout the whole episode. Jenna, I wrote down every single guess that Andy made. Ed also mentions in the commentary that he must have improvised like 20 of these. And he didn't. know until he watched the episode, which ones made it in.
你知道，《碟中谍2》或者《断箭》之类的，我不知道。我不知道迈克尔·斯科特是否看老香港电影。但也许他只是看了像尚格·云顿的《终极标靶》，然后说，我们需要做一个摄像机连接在纸飞机上的镜头。再说一次，这是我最喜欢的事情。那样拍整部电影会很棒。我喜欢在这个广告里投入的心思。太完美了。是的。我们以一个小标签结束这一集。那是安迪的采访。他还在试图弄清楚“奇巧”广告歌的结尾。他无法弄清楚。他在整集中都在为此挣扎。珍娜，我写下了安迪做的每一个猜测。埃德在评论音轨里也提到他一定即兴发挥了大约20个。他不知道直到他看了这一集，哪些被剪进去了。
Here's all of the wrong guesses Andy makes throughout this episode. Break me off a piece of that. Applesauce, Chrysler Carr, football cream, lumber tar, snickers bar, gray poupon, Claude Van Dam, Hair Ferman, Poison Gas, Nutra Sweet, and finally, Fancy Feast And he's convinced That's it, I did it Nailed it
这是安迪在这一集中做的所有错误猜测。给我掰一块那个。苹果酱，克莱斯勒车，足球奶油，木焦油，士力架，灰扑扑，克劳德·范·达姆，发酵人，毒气，代糖，最后，盛宴。他确信就是这个，我做到了，搞定了。
It's a cat food Break me off a piece of that fancy feast So good Before we go We have a final message from Jason You know my daughter Josie is 14 And she was a baby when I directed the office
那是猫粮。给我掰一块那个盛宴。太棒了。在我们走之前，我们有杰森的最后一条信息。你知道我的女儿乔西14岁了。当我导演《办公室》时，她还是个婴儿。
And to this day She has only seen one movie I've directed In fact up until recent She hadn't seen any film I'd ever directed and the only thing she had ever seen that I had directed was the office, of which she is a superfan, and that made her overwhelmingly proud of me. And it made me very grateful that I had directed the office because it put me in such high esteem of my child. But just to say, thank you, it really is a privilege to be part of the history of that show.
直到今天，她只看过我导演的一部电影。事实上，直到最近，她还没看过我导演的任何电影，她看过的唯一我导演的东西就是《办公室》，她是这部剧的超级粉丝，这让她对我感到无比自豪。这让我非常感激我导演了《办公室》，因为它让我在孩子心中有了很高的评价。但只是想说，谢谢，能成为那部剧历史的一部分真是一种荣幸。
Every once in a while, it'll pop up in a way, certainly when I'm doing interviews. It's one of the questions that always comes up. What was it like to direct the office? Because it's kind of like, you know, there's only so many people. who have walked on the moon and there's only so many people who've directed the office and I get to be one of those people. I've directed two episodes in fact. And it's something that I carry really proudly because, you know, I didn't create that thing. I just got to be a guest. You know, there's this presumption that you need to be angry to do comedy. And being at the office proves that
偶尔，它会以某种方式出现，当然是在我接受采访时。这是总是被问到的问题之一。导演《办公室》是什么感觉？因为这有点像，你知道，只有那么多人登上了月球，也只有那么多人导演过《办公室》，而我有幸成为其中之一。事实上，我导演了两集。这是我非常自豪的事情，因为，你知道，我没有创造那个东西。我只是有幸成为一名客人。你知道，有一种假设认为你需要愤怒才能做喜剧。而在《办公室》的经历证明了那个
concept wrong because it was a group of some of the loveliest and funniest human beings I've ever met. So sweet. So sweet. And Josie, we're so good. We're so good. We're so glad we help make your dad cool. Yeah. There you go. Guys, thank you so much again for sending in your questions. And Jason, thanks for sending in all those clips. And we will be here next week talking about Branch Wars. It's another hidden gem. I think we're going to have a few hidden gems in a row. I'm predicting. See you next week, everybody. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and
概念是错误的，因为那是我见过的一群最可爱、最有趣的人。太甜了。太甜了。乔西，我们太好了。我们太好了。我们很高兴能帮你爸爸变得很酷。是的。就是这样。伙计们，再次非常感谢你们发来问题。杰森，谢谢你发来所有这些片段。我们下周会在这里讨论《分部战争》。这是另一颗隐藏的宝石。我预测我们接下来会连续有几颗隐藏的宝石。下周见，各位。感谢收听《办公室女士》的第二杯。这一集最初是与Earwolf合作创作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和
Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Juerkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Molly Nugent. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·尤金斯，我们的音频工程师和副制片人是莫莉·纽金特。Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。谢谢。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。